.
OKAY I THINK WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED HERE.
I MEAN.
MR ACOSTA.
LEMASTER ACOSTA. AT BIGELOW WELL
YEAH.
HARRY.
NO NO.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE.
IT'S A BUSY TIME OF THE YEAR
WHERE WE HAVE TO.
GO IN AND OUT TO PROCESS OF OUR
BILLS.
WONDER WHAT A WELCOME MISTER
COSTA.
WHO IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THIS
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE AND
AEROSPACE?
WHICH.
IS CONDUCTING THIS INFORMATION
HEARING TODAY ON THE FUTURE OF
TRAVEL ISSUES AND COMMERCIAL
SPACE TRANSPORTATION.
NOW.
I THINK BOTH FOR MYSELF AND FOR.
MR ACOSTA.
ALL OF US REPRESENTING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN PARTICULAR WE ARE
SO.
PROUD TO BE OF THE REPRESENT.
.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH I LIKE
TO CALL THE AEROSPACE CAPITOL OF
THE WORLD.
WE CONTINUE TO LEAD THE COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD AND.
INNOVATION ESPECIALLY IN THIS.
IT WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE
MODERN SPACE RACE.
COMPANIES LIKE A SPACE ACTS
VERSION ORBIT VIRGIN GALACTIC
AND MANY OTHERS.
ARE LEADING THE COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
AND.
THIS EXCITING NEW AREA OF THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY WHICH
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST.
INDUSTRIES IN FACT.
AS CHAIR OF THE.
OPAL I WE EVEN GOT MUSIC TO ADD
THE EXCITEMENT HERE.
.
AS CHAIR THEY AEROSPACE
COMMITTEE I LIKE TO US SITE THE
EIGHTY CURRENTLY STUDY.
FROM A COUPLE YEARS AGO THAT
TALKS ABOUT HOW.
AEROSPACE A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE THAT THE.
THE GROSS REVENUES IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
IS EQUIVALENT OR EXCEEDS THAT
OF THE.
CALIFORNIA'S AND ENTERTAINMENT
AND.
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES
COMBINED
SO.
AND AND THIS DE THE SPACE THE
MARS SPACE RACE IS ADDING TO
THAT.
THAT SEX APPEAL OF THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY IN IS MAKING THE
AEROSPACE.
A COOL SO I WANT TO WELCOME
EVERYONE. TO THIS.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE HAVE A
GREAT LINE UP OF OF SPEAKERS TO
SHARE.
HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE A.
MEMBERS COMING IN.
.
AS WE PROCEED BUT.
WANTED A TURN OVER TO MISTER
COSTA.
INDUCER GASES WELL AS TO ANY
OPENING COMMENTS YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR UP WITH.
HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST THIS
JOB SHADOWING ME TODAY FROM ONE
OF OUR FOSTER. PROGRAMS IN THIS
IS THE LEAN THAT BAD ASSN SHE'S
GOING TO BE WITH ME ALL DAY
LEARNING WHAT ITS LIKE TO RUN
AROUND THE CAPITAL.
IN AND EXPERIENCE A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT. WHAT WE DO HERE SHE'S
FROM THE POMMEL A CALIFORNIA THE
CENTRAL CENTRAL COAST AREA AND
WANTS TO BE A HISTORY TEACHER?
PERHAPS WHEN SHE AND WHEN SHE
GRADUATES NEXT YEAR AND GO ON TO
COLLEGE SHE ALREADY SELECTED SAC
STATE SO SHE'S GONNA BE IN. TO
GET TO KNOW OUR LOOK A RIVER
REMEMBER HER FACE BECAUSE SHE'S
GONNA BE IN THE CAPITAL AREA.
GOING TO SACK STATE AND WE
WELCOME YOU TO THIS SIDE. OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AYE JULIA AN
HONOR AND A PLEASURE TO SERVE
HERE ON. I.
YOU KNOW REPRESENT THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY SIMI VALLEY IS IN
A NORTH SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
WHERE WE HAVE VERY HIGH
CONCENTRATION I THINK WE SAY THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF. A
DEFENSE AND AEROSPACE
SUBCONTRACTORS.
BUT IN ANY EVENT YEAH IT'S A
VERY LARGE CONCENTRATION AND OF
COURSE A LOT OF PEOPLE WORKING
AREA OTHER AREAS INCLUDING THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY IN DOWN IN THE
SOUTH BAY WHERE MISTER MY TO
ACHIEVE REPRESENTS.
AND IT REALLY.
TOGETHER DOING A CREDIBLE JOB
WITH THAT THIS INDUSTRY AND IT'S
REALLY AN EXCITING THING HAVING
BEEN AND BEEN TO THEIR THAT
SPACE PORTS AND OF COURSE BEEN
TO. LAUNCHES IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
THAT'S REALLY TRUE AN HONOR TO
BE HERE SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO A PRESENTATION TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF STRUCTURE
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
AND I WELCOME THEM IS THAT AS.
HOPE THIS INSPIRES YOU NOT ONLY
BE BECOME A TEACHER BUT PERHAPS
A SOMEDAY. CONSIDER RUNNING FOR
OFFICE AND SERVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO INVITE
OUR FIRST PANEL.
SPACE TRAVEL ON SERVICES IN
EMERGENCY AND INDUSTRIES I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME TO THE TABLE AND
I THINK.
.
WELL I GUESS WE CAN NO ONE
WANTED TIME.
EVA AROUND A SENIOR MANAGER OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR SPACEX.
THINK YOU'RE GONNA START WITH A
VIDEO CAMERA.
THAT YOUR MUSIC TOO YEAH
I THINK IT'S A MATCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY TO DISCUSS
SOME OF THE REMARKABLE
DEVELOPMENTS IN COMMERCIAL SPACE
TRANSPORTATION. TAKING PLACE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IS TRULY LEADING THE
WORLD IN INNOVATION FOR
COMMERCIAL SPACE
TRANSPORTATION AND I'M PLEASED
TO BE HERE REPRESENTING MY MORE
THAN SIX THOUSAND SPACE ACTS
COLLEAGUES WERE WORKING
TIRELESSLY TO REVOLUTION EIGHT
SPACE TECHNOLOGY.
WE ARE IN A DYNAMIC AND EXCITING
TIME FOR COMMERCIAL SPACE
INDUSTRY.
SPACEX IT'S PROUD TO BE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS INNOVATION
WHETHER IT'S REUSABLE LAUNCH
VEHICLE SYSTEMS THE
TRANSPORTATION OF ASTRONAUTS
USING OUR CREW DRAGON SPACECRAFT
OR SUPPORTING THE AIRFORCE IN
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE LAUNCH
SERVICES FOR CRITICAL NATIONAL
ASSETS.
FROM THE BEGINNING SPACEX HAS
LEVERAGED AMERICAN AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIAN
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY TO
CREATE THE MOST ADVANCED SPACE
LAUNCH VEHICLES AND SPACECRAFT
IN HISTORY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
DEEPLY INTERWOVEN AND THE STORY
AND CONTINUES TO BE WHERE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF OUR MORE THAN
SIX THOUSAND EMPLOYEES ARE
BASED.
SPACEX HAS GROWN REMARKABLY
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TO WHERE WE
STARTED WITH JUST THREE
EMPLOYEES IN A GARAGE IN EL
SEGUNDO.
INDIA SEEN FIRST HAND OUR
EXTENSIVE OPERATIONS IN
HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA.
TODAY WE ARE PROUD TO PROVIDE A
DEPENDABLE AND AFFORDABLE RIDE
TO SPACE FOR NASA. THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
INTERNATIONAL CUSTOMERS AND THE
WORLD'S MOST SOPHISTICATED
COMMERCIAL SATELLITE OPERATORS.
WE REGULARLY CONDUCT I'M CRUDES
RESUPPLY MISSIONS TO AND FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
WITH OUR DRAGON SPACECRAFT
LAUGHS LATER THIS YEAR SPACEX
WILL BEGIN LAUNCHING AMERICAN
ASTRONAUTS ON AMERICAN ROCKETS
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
SPACE SHUTTLE WAS RETIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN.
COMMERCIALLY SPACEX HAS RESTORED
THE UNITED STATES AS THE LEADER
IN GLOBAL SATELLITE LAUNCH FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES.
SPACEX IS NOW THE LEADING
PROVIDER OF COMMERCIAL SATELLITE
LAUNCH GLOBALLY OVERTAKING THE
FRENCH AND THE RUSSIANS IN
MARKET SHARE THIS YEAR WE WILL
LAUNCH THE MAJORITY OF THE
WORLD'S COMMERCIAL SATELLITES.
THIS MEANS CALIFORNIA JOBS AND
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
THREE THROUGHOUT SPACEX'S PATH
FROM OUR UPSTART BEGINNINGS IN
EL SEGUNDO CALIFORNIA HAS PLAYED
AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
OUR HAWTHORNE HEADQUARTERS
CONVERTED FROM AN ABANDONED IN
BLIGHTED AEROSPACE SICILY TO
STATE OF THE ART ROCK AND
SPACECRAFT FACTORY. REMAINS WERE
WE UNDERTAKE ESSENTIAL COMPANY
OPERATIONS SUCH AS DESIGN
ENGINEERING PRODUCTION AND
MISSION CONTROL.
BEYOND HAWTHORNE SPACEX HAS
ESTABLISHED A NETWORK OF
SUPPLIERS TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE HIGHEST QUALITY
MATERIALS AND PARTS.
WE WORK WITH OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA SUPPLIERS
RANGING FROM SMALL BUSINESSES TO
LARGE COMPANIES AND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN WE I SPENT
OVER TWO BILLION. WITH THESE
CALIFORNIA SUPPLIERS TO SUPPORT
OUR BUSINESS OPERATIONS.
SPACEX NOT ONLY DESIGNS AND
BUILDS THE WORLD'S MOST ADVANCED
ROCKETS AND SPACECRAFT IN
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO LAUNCH THEM
HERE.
SPACEX MAINTAINS A WEST COAST
LAUNCH AND LANDING SITE AS WELL
AS A PAYLOAD INTEGRATION
FACILITY AT SPACE LAUNCH COMPLEX
FOR LOCATED IN VANDENBERG
AIRFORCE BASE.
THIS COMPLEX SERVES AS A CRUCIAL
LAUNCH PLATFORM FOR COMMERCIAL
AND NATIONAL SECURITY PAYLOADS.
WE REINTRODUCED COMMERCIAL
LAUNCH FROM VANDENBERG AND TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN AND HAD SINCE
LAUNCH MULTIPLE COMMERCIAL
SATELLITES FROM VANDENBERG. THE
ONLY COMPANY CURRENTLY DOING SO.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE SPACEX
HAS ALSO CALLED THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES HOME TO ITS RECOVERY
EFFORTS FOR BOTH THE DRAGON AND
FALCON NINE. AND SPACEX JUST
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED TO.
THAT IT PLANS TO EXPAND THE
OPERATION TO INCLUDE PRODUCTION
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR NEXT
GENERATION ROCK AND SPACECRAFT.
OVERALL SPACEX'S CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES IMPACT OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA JOBS AND
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS SPACEX
PRODUCTION. LAUNCH AN
ADMINISTRATIVE FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA EXCEEDED SEVEN
BILLION ECONOMIC IMPACT MAJORITY
WHICH WAS REMAIN HAS BEEN
RETAINED IN THE GREATER
CALIFORNIA MARKET.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
YOUR INVITATION TO TESTIFY TODAY
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INITIATIVES TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE INDUSTRY I
LOOK FORWARD TO QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IBM.
I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS.
WELL ASK.
.
NOW WHAT WHEN WE GO WITH EACH
SPEAKER I WENT TIME BUT I WANTED
TO. WELCOME THEM MISTER LACKEY
TO.
THE COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT MR
LACKEY ALSO REPRESENTS.
MANY OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY MISTER LACKEY
WHICH I LIKE TO.
SEE ANY OPENING REMARKS THAT WE
TO COME TO LISTEN TO ME I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL BEING HERE. THIS
INDUSTRY REALLY DESERVES ARE OUR
GREATEST
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU BRING THE
ENTIRE WORLD BENEFITS FROM THIS
SIDE OF THIS INDUSTRY AND. WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THAT TECH
CALIFORNIA ALSO REAPS A GREAT
DEAL OF BENEFIT FROM YOUR. SO
WITH. THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
RIGHT.
SO. I'M IS BEREND IT AND I'M
PRONOUNCING GOOD YEAH YEAH RIGHT
OKAY. WELL YOU KNOW WE ALL
CALIFORNIANS WERE VERY PROUD
THAT.
THAT SPACE ACTS.
HAS THEY'RE GROWN FROM AS YOU
INDICATED THREE EMPLOYEES IN EL
SEGUNDO IN TWO THOUSAND TWO TWO
NOW OVER SIX THOUSAND.
.
WITH THE OVERALL IMPACT OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND.
JOBS.
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY CREATED.
ARM.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE.
THE HANDOUTS THAT WE PROVIDED
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS IS A A
JOINT STUDY PUT OUT BY THE LA
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION
AND THE SAN DIEGO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION.
AND.
THEY TALK ABOUT.
ONE OF THE.
THE CENTRAL CHALLENGES OF.
ESPECIALLY OF POLICYMAKERS.
HERE IN OUR STATE CAPITOL.
IS TO ENSURE THAT THE FUTURE.
.
YOU NO OF OUR AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY.
DEPENDING ON THE ABILITY.
OF.
POLICY MAKERS AS WELL AS THE
OVERALL ECOSYSTEM OF THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
TO BUILD THE EXISTING ECOSYSTEM
A TO ATTRACT THE NEXT GENERATION
AEROSPACE TECHNOLOGY FIRMS
SO.
YEAH I WANT TO START OFF BY
ASKING YOU IN THE WHAT.
WHAT WHY DID WHY DID CALIFORNIA
WHITE IS SPACEX?
STARRED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WISE IS STILL IN CAL.
WELL THERE THERE'S MANY REASONS
AND THERE'S A VERY RICH
AEROSPACE HISTORY HERE.
THE BUILDING THAT WE'RE IN NOW
WAS AN EXISTING AEROSPACE
BUILDING THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AND THEN
CREATE THIS ADVANCED ROCKET.
FACTORY I'M IN HAWTHORNE. AYE
THERE'S ALSO DEEP SUPPLIER
NETWORK I BELIEVE AS I REMEMBER
ACOSTA AT REFERENCE THAT IS
OPENING REMARKS AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
AND REALLY YOU KNOW WORK WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY FOR THAT.
IN THERE'S GREAT EDUCATIONAL
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS HERE AND
PEOPLE WHO I KNOW BRING A WEALTH
OF KNOWLEDGE WITH THEM. AND YOU
KNOW.
IT ISN'T IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU
KNOW TECHNICALLY SKILLED WORKERS
AT WE DO MANUFACTURING AND
PRODUCTION IN OUR FACILITY. I'M
AND SO WORKERS FROM ALL
DIFFERENT LEVELS WITH THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT AROUND THERE
WERE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT SO FOR ALL THOSE REASONS
CALIFORNIA IS A GREAT PLACE FOR
US TO BUILD AND GROW.
OKAY.
SO.
WORK FOR SUPPLY SYSTEM
EDUCATION RESEARCH.
THOSE ARE.
THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD NOT ONLY
FROM SPACE EXPENDABLE SO FROM
MANY.
AEROSPACE COMPANIES THE REASON
WHY.
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO LEAD
AND AEROSPACE INNOVATION.
WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
OF?
OF OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA.
SURE SO I THINK WHAT WE FIND IS%
WERE ALWAYS OUT WORKING TO WITH
THE LOCAL ECONOMY TO ENSURE THAT
WERE RECRUITING AS MANY PEOPLE
AS POSSIBLE. ENSURING THAT WE
CAN KEEP UP WITH THE PRODUCTION
MEANS WE FOUND HERE AND IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS.
WE'VE RAMPED UP OUR NEED TO
LAUNCH AND A MUCH MORE FREQUENT
PACE AND SO WE'VE BEEN REALLY I
AM FORTUNATE IN THAT RESPECT BUT
ALSO RENTING UP TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE HERE ARE. YOU KNOW BEING
PROMOTED IN STEM EDUCATION THAT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT STEM
EDUCATION LOCALLY SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO PRODUCE.
IT PEOPLE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY AND THAT ARE SKILLED
FOR THE INDUSTRY AS WELL.
WHAT ABOUT?
?
YOU KNOW OFTEN WE WE HEAR. THAT.
CALIFORNIA CAN BE A DIFFICULT
PLACE TO DO BUSINESS WHAT IT'S
BEEN SPACEX'S EXPERIENCE SO AND
YOU KNOW I THINK AGAIN
CONTINUING TO THE PORT. CATIONS
ONE OF OUR BIG PRIORITIES BUT
ALSO AS STABILITY IN POLICY SO I
WANTED TO PERSONALLY THANK YOU
FOR IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
INTRODUCING AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
WHICH I AM. ENSURE THAT WE HAD
SOME STABLE TAX POLICY WHEN IT
CAME TO SPACE LAUNCH AND.
ALSO AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT WITH AB THIRTY
ONE NINETY SEVEN TO CONTINUE
THAT POLICY SO YOU KNOW
CONTINUING POLICIES LIKE THAT
LOOKING AT STABILITY THAT'S YOU
KNOW THOSE ARE THE WAYS THAT YOU
CAN CONTINUE SUPPORT EFFORT
ALSO.
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT STEM
EDUCATION AT ALL LEVELS WHETHER
ITS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL JUNIOR
HIGH COLLEGE AND KEEPING THAT IN
THE FOREFRONT OF EDUCATION.
ALRIGHT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
JUST THE EP TOUCHED ON IT
BRIEFLY. OBVIOUSLY WE HELP WE
UNDERSTAND THE THE NEED FOR THE
THE HIGHER LEVEL EDUCATION WE
GOT GREAT INSTITUTIONS SEEM
LIKE.
YOU KNOW CAL TECH OR UC SYSTEM
ARE CSU SYSTEM THAT IT'S GOOD
FEEDER. WHAT ABOUT SOME OF THE?
I'LL ENTRY LEVEL IF YOU WILL
JOBS I'M SURE YOU NEED A LOT OF.
SKILLED LABOR PEOPLE THAT KNOW
HOW TO. YOU KNOW WELL THAN MEN
AND BUILD THINGS WHAT WHAT KIND
OF TALK A BIT ABOUT THAT PROCESS
AND WHAT WILL COME OF EMPLOYER
LOOKING FOR THEIR HOW WE CAN
HELP WITH THAT.
YES SO WE WORK A LOT WITH THE
LOCAL ECONOMY WE HIRE LOCALLY
AND SPECIFICALLY WITH OUR AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAD THOSE ARE
THE PLACES WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH AND TO GET MORE OF
THE. TECHNICIANS GET THEM INTO
THE FACTORIES ARE DOING THOSE.
KINDS OF WORK THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN ALONE.
TRADE HOWEVER HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
FROM LOCAL CONNED COLLEGES
THROUGH AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM TO GET THEM. THE THE
SKILLS THEY NEED BUT THE OTHER
THING IS ALSO YOU KNOW PEOPLE
FROM DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES ALSO
HAVE THE SKILLS THAT WE CAN ALSO
TRANSLATE THAT. AS WELL.
SO THE LOCAL ECONOMY IS HELPING
US WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW WE OF JUST FOLLOWING UP
ON THAT NOW. YEAH WE OFTEN HEAR
ABOUT TO.
A SKILLS GAP IN CALIFORNIA THAT.
THAT WHILE THE JOBS EXIST WE IT
AT THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH OF THE
SKILLED WORKERS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF STEM BUT.
.
AS A I THINK MR ACOSTA HAS A
PARTICULAR PASSION FOR.
ARCURI TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ARE. IS SPACEX ARE ARE
WE GETTING OUR ARE WE A
EDUCATING AND TRAINING ENOUGH
FOR SHEET METAL WORKERS AND
WELDERS.
YES THERE IS THERE IS DEFINITELY
A NEED FOR THAT AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND OTHER
TECHNICAL COLLEGES COLLEGES TO
KIND OF TAP INTO THAT BUT THAT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE INDUSTRY AS A
WHOLE.
CURRENT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
SHEDDING.
ALL RIGHT NEXT TO LIKE TO
WELCOME WELL POMERANTZ THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF SPECIAL PROJECTS
FOR VIRGIN ORBIT.
FANTASTIC WELL GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY SOMEONE
ACOSTA THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
NOT ONLY FOR DOING US THE HONOR
OF GIVING US THE INVITATION TO
COME UP AND SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY
BUT FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP.
AS A CALIFORNIA AND AND AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN A LIFELONG
DIE HARD ENTHUSIAST FOR
EVERYTHING AEROSPACE I'M HAVING
THE OPPORTUNITY DEAD TO WORK.
THROUGH THAT I LOVE IN A STATE
WHERE WERE SURROUNDED BY SO MANY
INSPIRING COMPANIES AND
GOVERNMENT FACILITIES.
IS REALLY INCREDIBLE TO ME AND
AND KNOW THAT COULD HAPPEN
WITHOUT LEADERSHIP AT THAT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND AT THE
STATE LEVEL SO I AM TRULY
APPRECIATIVE THAT. YOU MAY JUST
A MOMENT HERE I WILL.
THERE THERE'S THE MOUSE I'LL
CALL UP A QUICK PRESENTATION I
WANTED TO JUST GIVE YOU A QUICK
OVERVIEW AS WELL AS A STATUS
UPDATE ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON AT
THE VARIOUS COMPANIES THAT ARE
WITH IN THE.
THE VIRGIN SPACE PORTFOLIO AS
IT WERE I SHOULD BE SPEAKING
TODAY ABOUT THREE DIFFERENT
COMPANIES.
THAT ALL HAVE A FEW THINGS IN
COMMON AYE ONE IS A GENERAL
PURPOSE WHICH IS ALL ABOUT
DEMOCRATIZING ACCESS
SPACE ARE ALLOWING NOT NOT ONLY
PIONEERING AGENCIES LIKE NASA
AND UNITED STATES AIRFORCE THAT
HAVE EXPORTS SPACE SO WELL FOR
SO LONG. NOT ONLY ALLOWING THEM
TO CONTINUE TO DO MORE ON THE
SAME BUDGET OR EVEN WITH GLASS.
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT I
KNEW START UPS LIKE YOU HEAR UP.
FROM MIGHT FRONT FROM MY FRIEND
CALLING MISTER CASEY IN JUST A
MOMENT I UNIVERSITIES LIKE THE
GREAT CAL STATE UNIVERSITIES.
TO TO HAVE THEM BE ABLE TO
EXPLORE SPACE MORE AND MORE
OFTEN AS WELL THE OTHER THING WE
HAVE IN COMMON OF COURSE IS OUR
FOUNDER.
SIR RICHARD BRANSON AYE SIR
RICHARD IS THAT IS THAT IS A
UNIQUE INDIVIDUAL HE IS NOT AN
ENGINEER I OR A PHYSICIST.
HE IS THAT HE'S A BUSINESS
PERSON HE'S A SERIAL
ENTREPRENEUR AND THERE ARE
CURRENTLY ABOUT SIXTY COMPANIES
IN THE WORLD WITH VIRGIN IN THE
NAME AND THEY RANGE EVERYTHING
FROM. BANKS TO RAIL LINE'S TO
CRUISE SHIPS TO HOTELS TO RADIO
STATIONS TO JUST ABOUT ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN THINK OF I'M
RICHARD AT RICHARD HAS TRIED IT.
NOT RICHARD I GREW UP WATCHING
THE EARLY EXPLOITS OF THE NASA
ASTRONAUTS WATCHING YOU KNOW
NEIL AND BUZZ HOP AROUND ON THE
SURFACE OF THE MOON AND THAT
WANT TO DO THAT WHEN HE WHEN HE
GREW UP. AND THE INDUSTRY HAS
NOT INVOLVED IN A WAY SUCH THAT
HE'S ABLE TO BUY A TICKET TAKE
TO GO TO SPACE HIMSELF SO. HE
HAD THAT KIND OF CLASSIC
ENTREPRENEURS REACTION OF SAYING
WELL HERE'S THE THING I WOULD
REALLY LIKE THAT I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO PAY FOR THAT NO ONE
SELLING SO I SHOULD PROBABLY
START SELLING THAT.
AND THAT WAS THE DAWN OF OF OF
RICHARD'S AND INVOLVEMENT IN THE
AIRSPACE COMMUNITY STARTING WITH
VIRGIN GALACTIC NOW THERE ARE A
TOTAL OF AT THREE DIFFERENT
COMPANIES.
VIRGIN GALACTIC AND THE
SPACESHIP COMPANY AT WORK VERY
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER ON HUMAN
SPACE FLIGHT SUMMIT TALK ABOUT
THOSE FIRST AND I WILL SORT OF
REFER TO THEM AS A. ONE
COLLECTIVE ORGANIZATION ALTHOUGH
TECHNICALLY.
THEY THEY ARE SEPARATE VERGE
TACTIC BEING MORE EQUIVALENT TO
AN AIRLINE AND THIS BISHOP
COMPANY BE MORE EQUIPMENT TO THE
AIRFRAME MANUFACTURER LIKE THE
BOEING OR THE AIRBUS EQUIVALENT.
I WORKED AT VIRGIN GALACTIC FOR
OUT FOR SIX YEARS.
AND MY MAIN JOB WAS TO START
THE OTHER ONE VIRGIN ORBIT THE
SATELLITE LAUNCH BUSINESS ALL
JUST QUICKLY WALK YOU THROUGH
EACH OF THE TWO OF THOSE.
I'M SO VIRGIN GALACTIC IN THE
SPACESHIP COMPANY TOGETHER
COLLABORATE NAM ON BUILDING
TESTING FLYING AND SOON PUTTING
INTO COMMERCIAL OPERATIONS. THIS
VEHICLE IT'S ACTUALLY PART OF A
VEHICLE SET WHICH IS A FULLY
REUSABLE SUB ORBITAL HUMAN SPACE
FLIGHT SYSTEM DESIGNED TO CARRY
AYE EITHER ASTRONAUTS.
OR SCIENTIFIC EXPERIMENTS OR A
COMBINATION OF THE TWO AT INTO
SPACE ON VERY ROUTINE VERY SAFE
AND VERY AFFORDABLE FLIGHTS.
AND IT IS A AYE SOMEWHAT UNIQUE
LOOKING VEHICLE CERTAINLY AYE IF
YOU'RE USED TO ROCKETS IF YOU'VE
BEEN OUT OF VANDENBERG TO WATCH
FLIGHTS. WHEN YOU CAN SEE THEM
THROUGH THE FOG AT LEAST TELL
YOU'RE PROBABLY USED A ROCKET
STANDING ON THEIR TAILS AND
LAUNCHING FROM LAUNCH PADS ON
THE GROUND. AT THE VIRGIN GROUP
OF COMPANIES WE DO THINGS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY.
WE START WITH ROCKETS THAT ARE
STRAPPED UNDERNEATH THE WINGS OF
AIRPLANES MUCH LIKE CHUCK YEAGER
IN THE BELL X. ONE OR THE X.
FIFTEEN PROGRAM A LOT OF THE
GREAT LUMINARIES OF AEROSPACE.
AT WHICH OF COURSE FLEW RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NOT SO THE SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY
THAT VIRGIN OR VIRGIN GALACTIC
AND.
AND THE SPACESHIP COMPANY USE.
INVOLVES A CUSTOM BUILT CARRIER
AIRCRAFT CALLED THE WHITE
KNIGHTS TO WHICH IS A DUAL
FUSELAGE AIRCRAFT I ALWAYS SORT
OF JOKINGLY REFER TO IT AS A
CATAMARAN. AND THEN IN THE
CENTER THERE THE MORE TRIANGULAR
SHAPED.
DEVICE THAT YOU SEE IS AT A
SPACESHIP TO ARE FULLY REUSABLE
SUBORBITAL SPACECRAFT.
I TO WALK YOU THROUGH VERY
BRIEFLY THE AT THE FLIGHT
PROFILE AND THERE'S LOTS OF
WONDERFUL VIDEOS ONLINE THAT I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WATCH BY THAT.
BUT ONCE HE'S MY LIMITED TIME
HERE JUST TO TALK YOU THROUGH
THE LATEST UPDATES BUT BUT JUST
QUICKLY SUMMARIZE WHAT WE DO IS
WE ATTACH THE SPACESHIP TO THE
WING OF THE CARRIER AIRCRAFT IT
TAKES OFF. LIKE A NORMAL
AIRPLANE.
FROM A RELATIVELY NORMAL RUNWAY
AT A WONDERFUL FACILITY IN
MOJAVE THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING
ABOUT IN THE FOLLOWING PANEL.
DECLINES UP TO AN ALTITUDE OF
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND FEET.
AFTER WHICH THE ROCKET IS IT
SAFE REALLY RACED RELEASED FROM
THE WING OF THE AIRPLANE IT FREE
FALLS AWAY FROM THE AIRPLANE FOR
A FEW SECONDS TO GET GOOD
SEPARATION BETWEEN THE TWO
BEFORE IGNITING ITS HYBRID
ROCKET MOTOR. THAT TAKES YOU ON
A SUPERSONIC ROCKET POWERED
ABSENT ON YOUR BILL PASSES BE TO
SOUND ABOUT TEN SECONDS INTO THE
FLIGHT.
AND CONCILIATE CONTAIN
ACCELERATING UP TO ABOUT THREE
AND A HALF TIMES THE SPEED OF
SOUND. AND WILL CARRY TWO PILOTS
AND AS MANY AS SIX ASTRONAUTS IN
THE REAR OF THE VEHICLE UP ABOVE
NASA'S OFFICIALLY ACCEPTED
BOUNDARY OF SPACE. GIVING THEM A
FEW MINUTES OF TIME IN
WEIGHTLESSNESS TO FLOAT AROUND
WHETHER THEY'RE THERE PURELY FOR
FUN WHETHER THEY'RE THERE
BECAUSE THEY'RE TEACHERS IN
THERE DOING EXPERIMENT TO
INSPIRE OTHER STUDENTS. ARE
WHETHER THERE BECAUSE THEY'RE
PROFESSIONAL RESEARCHERS WHO
WORK FOR NASA LABS OR WORK FOR
UNIVERSITIES OR WORK FOR PRIVATE
COMPANIES LIKE SOME OF THE ONES
YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT LATER TODAY.
IT IS UP PRIMARILY THOUGHT OF
AS A SPUR SPACE TOURISM PROGRAM.
AND SPACE TOURISM IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT VIRGIN
GALACTIC DIES SPACE TOURIST ALSO
HAD THE ADVANTAGE OF THEY
CONTROL THEIR OWN BUDGET AND
THEY CAN BUY A TICKET ON THE
VEHICLE THAT'S NOT YET BUILT IF
THEY'RE EXCITED ENOUGH ABOUT IT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
PERSONALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
BECAUSE MY EDUCATIONAL
BACKGROUND IS IN THE SPACE
SCIENCES. IS THE ABILITY TO USE
THE SAME VEHICLE WITH THE SAME
PILOTS FLYING THE SAME FIGHT
TRAJECTORY AS A RESEARCH VESSEL.
ASA VIRGIN GALACTIC IN THE
SPACESHIP COMPANY OVER THE
COURSE OF ABOUT AN HOUR CAN
RECONFIGURE THE CABIN OF THE
VEHICLE BASICALLY PULLING OUT
SOME SEATS PUTTING IN SOME
RACKS.
AND HAVING A SYSTEM WHEREBY
EXPERIMENTS AGAIN THAT COULD BE
BUILT BY STUDENTS ARE COULD BE
BUILT BY NOBEL PRIZE WINNERS ARE
ANYONE IN BETWEEN.
CAN'T CAN FLY THEIR EXPERIMENTS
TO SPACE I TYPICALLY THEY BE
FINE THINGS EXPERIMENTS THAT ARE
EACH ABOUT THE SIZE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN MAYBE A MICROWAVE OVEN
OR A DORM ROOM REFRIGERATOR. AND
THEY CAN SOMETIMES YOU CAN STACK
A FEW THOSE TOGETHER IF YOU NEED
A BIGGER EXPERIMENT BUT IT'S
ROUGHLY ROUGHLY IN THAT CLASS.
I'M THESE VEHICLES ARE BILLS
THIS IS REALITY AND THEIR NOT
YET IN COMMERCIAL SERVICE
BECAUSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO. TEST AND TEST AND
KEEP TESTING THESE AYE WE DO
WANT TO FLY.
CIVILIANS ON THESE VEHICLES
INCLUDING OUR BOSS RICHARD
BRANSON WANTS TO BE CUSTOMER
NUMBER ONE HOW WOULD YOU CAN
IMAGINE PUT SOME PRESSURE ON THE
ON THE ENGINEERS THE OPERATING
WORKFORCE TO ENSURE NOT ONLY
THAT HE'S GONNA COME HOME SAFELY
BUT THAT HE'S GONNA COME HOME
SMILING.
AND EXCITED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
ALL DOING.
SO AS I MENTIONED THE VEHICLE
SYSTEM INVOLVES TWO VEHICLES
THAT CATAMARAN LIKE CARRIER
AIRCRAFT WHICH WE CALL THE WHITE
KNIGHT TO.
AS OF TODAY THAT HAS FLOWN
SAFELY TWO HUNDRED FORTY SIX
TIMES IT HAS CREWMEMBERS ONBOARD
IN EVERY SINGLE FLIGHT THERE ARE
NO AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES HERE
THERE'S THESE ARE NOT DRONES
THESE ARE ALL. HUMAN PILOTED
SYSTEMS
I SO THAT'S FOR THE CARRIER
AIRCRAFT.
THE SPACESHIP ITSELF HAS THAT
HAS RECENTLY COMPLETED IT'S
TWELFTH FIGHT INCLUDING ITS
FIRST SUPERSONIC ROCKET POWERED
FLIGHT WHICH IS A REALLY MAJOR
MILESTONE.
FOR THE PROGRAM AYE IT DID GO.
ABOUT MACH ONE POINT EIGHT IF
I'M RECALLING CORRECTLY ON THAT
PARTICULAR FLIGHT.
WE HOPE TO EVENTUALLY BURN THE
ENGINE FOR FAR LONGER AS WE GET
COMFORTABLE DOING SO.
IT ALL.
IT'LL EVENTUALLY TAKE THE
VEHICLE AS A SET UP TO MACH
THREE POINT FIVE OR SO AND SO
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF ROOM TO
GO BY THATBUT OBVIOUSLY AS. AS
CALIFORNIANS KNOW BETTER THAN
ANYONE THAT THAT BARRIER WHEN
YOU CROSS THROUGH THE AT WITH
THROUGH THIS THROUGH THE SOUND
BARRIER IS AT SOME OF THE
TRICKIEST THINGS IN AND WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY DO
THAT.
I OUT WE ARE JUST BUILDING A
SPACE SHIP WERE BUILDING A SPACE
LINE IN A SPACE SHIP FACTORY.
AND SO HERE IS A RELATIVELY
RECENT CLAIMS FROM THE FROM THE
AYE SHOP FOR.
THANKS TO THAT THE INVESTMENT
WE RECEIVED IN PARTICULAR THANKS
TO THE TALENT OF OUR WORKFORCE
WE HAVE BEEN A BEGUN ASSEMBLY ON
THE NEXT TO SPACESHIPS. I
BELIEVE THAT.
ASSEMBLYMAN LACKEY IN AND I
THINK ASSEMBLYMAN ACOSTA YOU HAD
A CHANCE TO COME UP AND VISIT US
WEEKLY FOR WHICH WERE VERY
GRATEFUL AND YOU GOT A CHANCE TO
SEE THE NEXT TWO SPACESHIPS
WHICH WE LOVE MICHAEL AT A AND
R. D. AFTER OUT TO RICHARD'S
GRANDCHILDREN. NOW WHICH ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF BEING ASSEMBLING
AND HOPE WE'RE HOPING TO ENTER
INTO THE INTO THE FLEET QUITE
QUICKLY.
SO THAT'S VIRGIN GALACTIC IN THE
SPACE COME STATE SPACESHIP
COMPANY AND THE HUMAN SPACE
FLIGHT SIDE OF WHAT THE VIRGIN
GROUP IS DOING IN SPACE. NOW IN
A TRANSITION AND QUICKLY TALK
ABOUT THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BUSINESS WHICH IS VIRGIN ORBIT.
WAS MY CURRENT AT MY CURRENT
POSITION HERE.
AT THIS IS.
AGAIN DOING SOMETHING
PHILOSOPHICALLY VERY SIMILAR
WHICH IS MAKING SPACE FLIGHTS
MUCH MORE FREQUENT AND MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE WITHOUT SACRIFICING
ANY RELIABILITY. BUT INSTEAD OF
DOING THAT FOR ASTRONAUTS WERE
DOING THIS FOR FOR SMALL
SATELLITES.
NOT LIKE VIRGIN GALACTIC INTO
YOU SEE WE ALSO USE AN AIR
LAUNCH SYSTEM SO AGAIN INSTEAD
OF A ROCKET STANDING ON ITS TAIL
AT VANDENBERG AIRFORCE BASE OR.
CAPE CANAVERAL ANYONE ANYWHERE
ELSE WE START WITH A ROCKET THAT
STRAPPED UNDER THE WING OF A
CARRIER AIRCRAFT.
AND IN THIS CASE RATHER THAN
USING A CUSTOM BUILT CARRIER
AIRCRAFT WE USE THE WORLD'S MOST
RELIABLE HIGH THE PROVEN INITIAL
STAVING SAGE OF A ROCKET.
WE USE THAT OF A BOEING SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN ON IT IS NOWHERE NEAR
AS IMPRESSIVE ARE CAPABLE IN
MANY WAYS AS A FALCON NINE FOR
STAGE WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WEEK THEY THEY GET A STANDING
OVATION EVERY TIME THEY BRING
ONE OF THOSE HOMES WHICH REALLY
IS REMARKABLE. ABBOTT SIMPLY
HAVEN'T HAD THE ADVANTAGE OF
THEY'VE BEEN FINE FOR THIRTY OR
FORTY YEARS OF THEM FANTASTIC
SAFETY RECORD AND YOU CAN TURN
AROUND ABOUT FORTY FIVE TIMES.
IT DOES NOT GET US ANYWHERE NEAR
AS CLOSE TO SPACE OBVIOUSLY IS
THE FIRST STAGE BUT IT DOES GIVE
US A LITTLE BIT OF A HEAD START
ON ON THE WAY TO SPACE AND. GIVE
US A LOT OF.
OF RESPONSIVENESS A LOT OF THAT
LIKE WE CALL UP TIME THE ABILITY
TO EXACT ACCESS DIFFERENT ORBITS
WHICH IS PARTICULAR. BUT WHICH
IS ADAM PARTICULARLY USEFUL
OFTEN MAYBE TO OUR GOVERNMENT
CLIENTS BUT ALSO INCREASINGLY TO
OUR COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS AS
WELL.
WE'VE PAIRED THAT.
VERY PROVEN AT AIRCRAFT WITH AS
SIMPLE A ROCKET AS WE CAN MAKE.
AND IT IS NOT THE HIGHEST
PERFORMANCE ROCKET IF YOU LOOK
AT OUR THRUST NUMBERS NEXT TO.
NEXT TO A FALCON NINE OR SOME
THE OTHER ROCKETS ON THE MARKET
WE LOOK MINUSCULE IMPUNITY BY
COMPARISON AND WE DO THAT ON
PURPOSE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE THE
PRICES LOW AS WE CAN POSSIBLY
MAKE.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO TAKE
HUMANS BEING BEINGS TO MARS AS
WONDERFUL AS THAT IS.
MY WIFE WORKS FOR THE JET
PROPULSION LABORATORY ON MARS
MISSION SO I SO I'M I'M ALL IN
FAVOR OF MORE THOSE KINDS OF
MISSIONS WERE JUST SIMPLY
ANSWERING A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
I WHICH IS HOW HOW HOW DO WE
MAKE THE A TICKET PRICES LOWEST
POSSIBLE WE DO THAT THEIR
SIMPLICITY. AND WE DO THAT
THROUGH SOME ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING TECHNIQUES
I STARTING JUNE ENGAGED NOT ONLY
THREE PRINTING BUT REALLY THE
NEXT GENERATION OF SOME OF THE
pMANUFACTURING TECHNIQUES SO
THAT
WE CAN BUILD THESE. IN
RELATIVELY HIGH NUMBERS I'M TO
PUT THIS IN INSISTS THAT IN A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT LAST YEAR
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD THERE WERE
NINETY LAUNCHES TO SPACE. THAT'S
EVERY ROCKET OF EVERY
CONFIGURATION WITH OTHER HUMANS
ON TOP OR SATELLITES WITH ITS
MILITARY OR COMMERCIAL OR
CIVILIAN. WE WOULD LIKE TO DO
TWENTY FOUR FLIGHTS PER YEAR IN
THE VERY NEAR TERM I'M OUT OF
OUR OUT OF OUR LUNCH FACILITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I NEVER FACTORED PARTICULAR
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO SO WE'D
LIKE TO BE BUILDING AT.
I USE HIGH RATE IN IN AIR QUOTES
A VERY HIGH RATE FOR THE ROCKET
INDUSTRY EVEN IF IT'S LOW RATE
COMPARED TO AT SOME OF THE
THINGS MANUFACTURED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A QUICK
UPDATE ON THE PROGRAM.
WE PURCHASED THE AIRPLANE.
IT WAS NICELY AN AIRPLANE THAT
WAS BEING FLOWN BY ONE OF OUR
SISTER COMPANIES VIRGIN ATLANTIC
AND LIKE MOST AIRLINES THEY
DON'T OWN THEIR AIRPLANES THERE
RELEASE THEM THEIR LEASE WAS
COMING UP AND WE WERE ABLE TO
AT.
TO COME IN AND BUY THE AIRPLANE.
IT JUST SO HAPPENED THAT IT WAS
FLYING UNDER THE NAME COSMIC
GIRL WHICH MADE IT SEEM A LITTLE
BIT LIKE FATE THAT WE'RE USING
IT AS A. AS A LAUNCH PLATFORM
FOR OUT FOR SATELLITES OF A
GARDEN AND LOOK BACK ON OUR HOME
WORLD AS WELL AS EXPLORE THE
COSMOS THERE. SO THE AIRCRAFT IS
UP IN FLIGHT TEST NOW WE WE DID
A FAIRLY EXTENSIVE MODIFICATION
TO THE AIRCRAFT AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE NOT ONLY DOING THINGS
LIKE PULLING OUT ALL THE SEATS
IN. THE LABORATORIES IN THE
GALLEYS IN THE OVERHEAD BINS BUT
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
WIRED THE AIRPLANE TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO AND CARRIED THE ROCKETS
SAFELY. I'M SEVEN FOUR SEVENS IT
TURNS OUT ARE ACTUALLY ALREADY
BUILT TO CARRY A PAYLOAD UNDER
THEIR WINGS ALTHOUGH THEY DON'T
DO IT TERRIBLY OFTEN WE'RE
LEVERAGING A PRE EXISTING BIT OF
ENGINEERING CALLED THE FIFTH
ENGINE CARRY POSITION.
SO IF YOU PUT YOURSELF IN THE
POSITION OF THE CEO OF AN
AIRLINE IF YOU EVER NEED TO
ORDER AN EXTRA JET ENGINE SO YOU
HAVE INVENTORY ON HAND. THE WAY
THAT'S DELIVERED TO YOU IS
CARRIED UNDER THE WING OF THE
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN. AM WHAT WE'RE
CARRYING IS NOT AN AIRCRAFT
ENGINE IT'S A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT SIZE LIVE A DIFFERENT
MASS.
BUT IT WAS AWFULLY NICE TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO ENGINEERING THAT
BOEING DID THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS
AGO THAT HAS A PERFECT SAFETY
RECORD AND SAY OKAY LET'S USE
THAT AND HOW DO WE HOW DO WE
BUILD UPON THAT.
I'M WE HAVE BUILT BY SEVERAL
ROCKETS AND ALSO YOU SOME MORE
PICTURES OF THOSE LATER BY THIS
IS THAT A PHOTOGRAPH OF THE
FIRST FULLY ASSEMBLED ROCKET TO
LEAVE OUR FACTORY DOORS AT LATE
LAST YEAR. WHICH WENT UP TO OUT
TO THE MOJAVE AIR AND SPACE PORT
WHERE WE CONDUCTED A FULL SET OF
WHAT WE CALL LAUNCH CAMPAIGN
REHEARSALS THESE ARE
ESSENTIALLY.
WET DRESS REHEARSALS WHERE WE
PRACTICE MATING THE.
THE ROCKET TO SOMETHING THAT
STIMULATES THE WING OF THE
AIRPLANE WE PRACTICE FUELING IT
WOULD PASS IT BY TRIES AND WE
GET ALL OF OUR.
ALL OF OUR HARD WORKING
TECHNICIANS IN AN OPERATOR'S AT
THEIR AT THEIR VARIOUS POSITIONS
IN MISSION CONTROL AND DO
EVERYTHING UP INTO THE MOMENT
WHERE WE WOULD PRESS GO.
ESSENTIAL AND I JUST TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'VE THAT WERE ABLE
TO RUN THOSE PROCESSES UP VERY
GRATEFUL TO TO REPORT THAT THOSE
WENT OFF EXTRAORDINARILY WELL.
WE HAVE FINISHED DEVELOPING ARE
NOW IN THE LATER PHASES OF
QUALIFYING ALL OF THE MAJOR
STRUCTURES OF THE ROCKET. FOR
THE MOST PART STRUCTURES TESTING
IS LIKE WATCHING PAINT DRY
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOOKING AT A TANK
AND HOPING IT DOESN'T BREAK AT
THIS IS ONE OF THE MORE
INTERESTING IMAGES THAT I COULD
FIND OF A VAT OF AYE AYE NOSE
CONE OR A PAYLOAD FAIRING OPEN.
BUT WE ARE REALLY PUTTING
EVERYTHING THROUGH ITS PACES
ESSENTIALLY WE HAVE AN ENTIRE
SECTION OF OUR FACTORY THAT I'D
LIKE TO. LOVINGLY REFER TO AS
THE MEDIEVAL TORTURE CHAMBER
WHERE WE TAKE ALL THE PARTS THAT
WE BUILT AND WE TRY AND BREAK
THEM UP ON THE THEORY THAT IF
THEY'RE EVER GONNA BREAK WE'D
LIKE TO BREAK THEM ON PURPOSE IN
THE FACTORY BEFORE THEY BREAK BY
ACCIDENT SOMEWHERE ELSE. AYE SO
THAT'S THE PROCESS THAT WE ARE
WERE IN THE THICK OF RIGHT NOW.
I'M WE'VE DESIGNED ALL OF OUR
OWN ROCKET ENGINES.
RATHER THAN BUYING THEM FROM AN
OVERSEAS SUPPLIER AND I'M WE
HAVE THAT WE HAVE BUILT THOSE IN
HOUSE.
AND ARE HAVE BEEN TESTING THEM
FOR MANY YEARS AND THEY ARE
DESIGNED AND BUILT.
AND AND I IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TESTED UP IN KERN COUNTY I'M WE
HAVE BEEN TESTING THEM FOR A
LONG TIME AT FULL DURATION AND
AT FULL THRUST.
THE TESTING IS NOT DONE AND IN
FACT WILL NEVER BE DONE YOU KNOW
AUTOMOBILE ENGINE STILL GET
BETTER EVERY YEAR AND THOSE HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE SO YOU
NEVER QUITE PUT THE PEN DOWN. WE
ARE TO THE POINT WHERE WE HAVE
DONE ALL THE RISKIEST THINGS NOW
WHICH I NEED TO DO OTHER ISSUES
THINGS EVERY TIME AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY DID THAT THE HEART
OF THE PROGRAM THAT WE ARE IN
RIGHT NOW.
AND THEN LASTLY HERE'S JUST A
QUICK SHOT THIS IS FROM ABOUT
TWO WEEKS AGO.
OF OUR OF OUR FACILITY I'M AT
THE DOUGLAS PARK IN THAT IN LONG
BEACH.
AS YOU CAN SEE THERE WE ARE
JUST BUILDING A ROCKET WE ARE
BUILDING MANY ROCKETS I'M WE
HEARD. WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL IN
THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY WERE
REALLY HARDWARE RICH
AND SO WE'VE TAKEN THE SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL POSITION OF?
NOT JUST BUILDING ONE FLIGHT
ONE ROCKET PRIOR TO ARE MADE IN
FLIGHT GOING AHEAD AND TAKING
THE RISK.
BUILDING MULTIPLE OF THEM.
WE TRY NOT TO BE GUILTY OF
HUBRIS AND WE RECOGNIZE THE
HISTORY OF THE MADE IN FIGHTS OF
ROCKETS THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS
GO PERFECTLY I'M SURE WE'LL FIND
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
IMPROVE.
BUT AT THE OFFICE. GOING HAVE
OUR ENTIRE TEAM FOCUS ON THOSE
PARTS WE WANT TO IMPROVE AND SAY
HEY EVERYTHING ELSE IS BUILT
EVERYTHING ELSE IS READY WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO GO WERE READY TO
FLY AGAIN. THIS ORBITER O'CLOCK
THIS IS VIRGIN ORBIT.
AND LASTLY I WANT AND JUST WITH
SOME SOME NOTES ABOUT OUR
ACTIVITIES IN THE COMMUNITY.
STEM EDUCATION IS THAT MATTER
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
PERSONALLY A LOT OF MY VOLUNTEER
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF BUSINESS
HOURS. ARE AND NOW SPEAKING TO
STUDENTS OP I DO PARTICULARLY
THE COLLEGE LEVEL BUT MY SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE DOING IT ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO THE.
TO THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL LEVEL
I'M WE OPEN UP A AT VIRGIN ORBIT
WE OPEN UP OUR FACTORY TO LOCAL
SCHOOLS ON THE THIRD SATURDAY OF
EVERY SINGLE MONTH AND AND BRING
IN LOTS OF OTHER TOURS UP BY
EXCEPTION FOR FOR CLASSROOMS
THAT CAN'T COME IN ON. ON
WEEKENDS
NOW WE HAVE BROUGHT THAT.
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS IN THROUGH THE FACTORY
AS WELL AS GOING OUT INTO
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS YOUTH
ORGANIZATIONS ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I'D TO SAY NOTHING OF THE
VARIOUS THINGS THAT WE DO ONLINE
THROUGH SKY PER WHAT YOUR PICK
YOUR FAVORITE THAT.
ONLINE TOOL AYE SO REALLY PRIZE.
GOING OUT THERE AND INSPIRING
THE NEXT GENERATION OF OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO COME AND
WORK FOR US OR OVERCOME THAT
MISTER CASEY AND START THEIR OWN
SATELLITE COMPANY THAT MIGHT
WANT TO BUY A FLIGHT FROM US OR
JUST OTHERWISE CONTRIBUTE TO
THAT. THE WEALTH OF HUMAN
KNOWLEDGE AYE WE ALSO HAVE BEGUN
CONTRIBUTING IN THE FORM OF
SCHOLARSHIPS AND GRANTS THAT GO
OUT TO STUDENTS AT PRIMARILY
HERE IN AT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN LASTLY AGAIN WE WE
REALLY PRIZE.
I BUILDING BUILDING THE WORK
FORCE BETWEEN THE THREE
COMPANIES I'VE SPOKEN TO YOU
ABOUT VIRGIN GALACTIC THE
SPACESHIP COMPANY IN VIRGIN
ORBIT WE UP EMPLOYEE WELL OVER A
THOUSAND FULL TIME EMPLOYEES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THOSE ARE OVERWHELMINGLY VERY
HIGH SKILL VERY HIGH WAGE JOBS.
WE ALSO.
ARE BRINGING A LOT OF NOT ONLY
THE MOST SEASONED AND
EXPERIENCED PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE COME TO US FROM SPACE ACTS
OR BOEING ARE LOUGHEED OR
NORTHROP OR NASSER THE AIRFORCE
WE ALSO EMPLOYEE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE FOR WHOM WE ARE THEIR
FIRST JOB DIRECTLY OUT OF
SCHOOL.
AT ONE OF OUR GREAT ENTRYWAYS
INTO THAT.
PROGRAM IS.
IS A SORT OF OUR STEM PIPELINE
OF STUDENTS COMING TO US AS
INTERNS
AND WE'VE GOT WE'VE ACTUALLY
JUST SET UP A WHOLE SECTION OF
OUR FACTORY FLOOR AYE DOWN AT
MERGING OR DIDN'T KNOW VIRGIN
GALACTIC IS DONE THE SAME FOR.
OUR NEWEST CROP OF INTERNS WHO
ALL SHOW UP ON MONDAY.
WE DO DRAW FROM SCHOOLS ALL
AROUND THE UNITED STATES BUT
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE FANTASTIC
STRENGTH OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM A LOT OF
THOSE STUDENTS COME FROM OUR
FROM RIGHT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WANTED TO MENTION
THAT AS WELL I AGAIN IT'S BEEN A
REAL PLEASURE AND AN HONOR TO
SPEAK WITH YOU AND I VERY MUCH
LOOK FOR TO YOUR QUESTION.
I VERY MUCH WANT TO WELCOME THE.
CHAIR OF OUR ASSEMBLY JOBS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
MS AYE QUIRK SILVA.
THIS QUIRK SILVA WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY NEW. WELCOMING REMARKS.
I DID COME IN AFTER YOU STARTED
BUT IT'S VERY VERY INTERESTING
PRESENTATION I CAN SEE HOW
EXCITED YOU ARE BY PRESENTING AT
AND I THINK A. JUST YOUR
ENTHUSIASM A PRESENTING AYE LIFE
I BELIEVE WOULD GET QUITE A FEW
STUDENTS INTERESTED. BUT ITEM IN
PLACE YOUR MANUFACTURING FRIENDS
BACK OUT THERE AND I KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE QUITE A. FEW OF
THE OTHER SUPPLIERS IN THAT AREA
SO I'M.
VERY EXCITED TO SEE YOU GUYS
INNOVATE THANK YOU VERY KIND
WORDS BRIGITTE.
ALRIGHT.
SO IF I MAY LIKE TO START OFF
WITH SOME QUESTIONS FOR MISTER
POMERANTZ.
.
LOT OF EXCITING STUFF.
ONE IS THE.
THE TARGET DATE FOR THEM.
GENERAL PUBLIC TO BE ABLE TO BUY
A TICKET AND GO OUT IN SPACE.
AS SOON AS WE CAN MAKE IT NAM A
RICHARD OBVIOUSLY IS INCREDIBLY
EAGER AS ARE AS ARE ALL OF US
AND WE'VE BEEN YOU KNOW ARE
POURING OUR HEARTS OUT INTO THE
SYSTEM FOR FOR OUT FOR A LONG
TIME AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT UP
IN THE AIR. THAT SAID OBVIOUSLY.
SAFETY IS THAT SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT HERE WE WE WE WON'T
PUT UPON THE VEHICLE UNTIL WE
ARE VERY CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
DO SO IN A WAY THAT AS I
MENTIONED NOT ONLY WILL BE SAFE
IT WILL BE REALLY ENJOYABLE. I'M
ON THE AYE HUMAN SPACE FLIGHT
SIDE AS I MENTIONED.
VIRGIN GALACTIC ARE ARE IN THE
TEST FLIGHT PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
AND THEY HAVE BITTEN OFF A LOT
OF THE MAJOR RISKS BUT STILL
HAVE SOME YET TO GO. I THINK THE
ASPIRATION AS THAT YOU KNOW THAT
THAT IS THAT THAT THAT. ROUTINE
FLIGHTS OF COMMERCIAL PASSENGERS
AREN'T AREN'T TOO FAR OFF YOU
KNOW MORE IN THAT YEAR. TWO
YEARS KIND OF RANGE IT CERTAINLY
NOT DECADE BUT IT'S ALSO NOT
TOMORROW THERE'S THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE WORK TO DO. I'M
ON THE VERGE IN ORBIT SIDE OUR
AIM IS TO BE IN COMMERCIAL
SERVICE BEFORE THE END OF THIS
YEAR SO POINT OFTEN ORBITAL TEST
FLIGHT WHICH WILL HAVE PAYLOADS
ON BOARD BUT THEY'LL ALL BE OUR
OWN.
AND HOPEFULLY TO SUCCESSFULLY
EXECUTE THAT AND TO GET INTO
COMMERCIAL SERVICE THAT BEFORE
THE END OF THE YEAR.
SO I AM NOT SURE IF I HEARD YOU
RIGHT TELL THAT SPACE TOURISM
SIDE MADE ME AND ALWAYS TOUGH TO
SAY AND WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM FROM PAST MISTAKES ABOUT
GIVING TWENTY TO FIND A DATE ON
IT THEM OR SO IT IS PROBABLY
MORE IN. IN THE IN THE YOUR LIKE
TIME LIKE THAT A YEAR IS FROM
NOW AND IT COULD BE A LITTLE
SOONER IF EVERYTHING GOES
SWIMMINGLY PERFECT HA HA.
THINGS GENERALLY DON'T AS
THOUGH IT'S A COULD BE A LITTLE
LONGER THAN THAT BUT IT'S IN
THAT SORT OF ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
TO HAVE MISTER BRANSON POSSIBLY
YES BE. THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY
OUR AIM AHA. THAT'S EXCITING IT
IS EXCITING AYE SIR SO.
.
HE ALSO MENTIONED THAT YOU HAVE
A THOUSAND HIGHLY SKILLED HIGHLY
PAID JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
YEAH AND I.
HAPPY TO SEE THE.
THE MANUFACTURING OF OF SOME OF
THOSE.
ROCKETS TAKING PLACE IN THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH.
SO LIKE TO ASK YOU THE SAME
QUESTION I ASKED THE SPACEX Y.
CALIFORNIA. AYE AYE AYE EIGHT
OVERWHELMINGLY THE REASON WHY
ALL OF THESE BUSINESSES ARE IN
CALIFORNIA IS FOR THE TALENT AND
IT'S FOR THE IDEAS IT'S FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE ALREADY
HERE. YOU KNOW VIRGIN GALACTIC
WHICH WAS THE FIRST OF THE THREE
VIRGIN SPACE COMPANIES GOT ITS
START LICENSING TECHNOLOGIES
FROM SCALED COMPOSITES WHICH IS
NOW A SUBSIDIARY OF NORTHROP
GRUMMAN. AND THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN BASED.
IN IN MOJAVE RIGHT AT THE
MOJAVE AIR AND SPACE PORT.
THERE IS NO OTHER ORGANIZATION
IN THE WORLD THAT LIKE THAT THAT
HAS THAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGY AND
AND ALSO.
TO GIVE IT A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ADVERTISEMENT FOR MYSTERIES IN
THE NEXT PANEL THERE IS ANOTHER
FACILITY IN THE WORLD QUITE LIKE
MOJAVE AREN'T SPACEPORT IT'S
JUST A FANTASTIC PLACE.
TO HAVE REALLY CREATIVE IDEAS
AND TO GET THEM OUT IN THE FIELD
AND TO TEST THEM AND TO LEARN AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE IF IT'S A
BRILLIANT IDEA ARE TERRIBLE IDEA
OR SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN.
SIMILARLY FOR FOR VIRGIN ORBIT
WHEN WE STARTED TO SCALE UP AND
WE WERE MOVING OFF OF A FEW
IDEAS ON COMPUTER SCREENS AND
AND OUT INTO THE REAL WORLD. WE
NEEDED TO ACCESS A READY.
SUPPLY OF OF TALENTED LABORERS.
AND A FULL SUPPLY CHAIN AND AND
WE CERTAINLY FOUND THAT IN
SPADES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IF
YOU'LL PERMIT ME A BRIEF
ANECDOTE NAM WHEN WE FIRST MOVED
INTO OUR FACTORY RIGHT THERE IN
DOUGLAS PARK IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH.
AT THE TIME VIRGIN ORBIT HAD
ABOUT EVEN THOUGH WE WERE CALLED
VIRGIN ORBIT WITH THE TIME WE
WERE DEPARTMENT BUT I'LL USE THE
TERM VIRGIN ORBIT FOR
SIMPLICITY.
OF THE TIME WE HAD ABOUT THIRTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES AND HARDLY ANY
HARDWARE AND WE MOVED INTO A
BUILDING WITH A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
MANUFACTURING SPACE.
AT LITERALLY THE FIRST WEEKEND
THAT WE HELD THE KEYS TO THE
BUILDING WE HAD A JOB FAIR AND
AN OPEN HOUSE.
IN THE BUILDING.
WE WERE LOOKING TO HIRE ABOUT
FIFTY EMPLOYEES IN THE NEAR TERM
WE FIGURED IF WE CAN GET A
THOUSAND PEOPLE TO COME AND
APPLY FOR IT TALK ABOUT IT AT
ABOUT FIFTY JOBS WE BE FEELING
PRETTY GOOD. OUT WE STOPPED
COUNTING ONLY HAD SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THE PARKING LOT AND
THAT WAS AROUND ELEVEN AM THE
EVENT WENT FOR ANOTHER THREE OR
FOUR HOURS. TO JUST SORT OF
SHOWED US THAT THERE WAS A READY
WORK FORCE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
ALREADY INCREDIBLY DEDICATED AND
INCREDIBLY TALENTED IN THIS IN
THIS SECTOR.
AND THAT HAS CONTINUED TO RING
TRUE OUT WHEN WE NEED SOMETHING
WE CAN ALMOST ALWAYS FIND IT
WHETHER IT'S GOING NEXT DOOR TO
CAL STATE LONG BEACH. OR IT'S
TALKING TO RETIREES WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED THE AIRFORCE MISSION
OR THE NASA MISSION OVER THE
YEARS.
WE CAN'T FIND IT LOCALLY IT'S
NOT VERY HARD TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
TO COME AND MOVED TO CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT'S ANOTHER ANOTHER
BIG TOOL IN OUR TOOLKIT AS WELL.
MISS QUIRK SILVA AYE YOU MENTION
THAT THERE WERE ABOUT NINETY
FLIGHTS INTERNATIONALLY COM.
INTO SPACE.
HOW DO YOU COORDINATE THAT AS
FAR AS YOU WERE SAYING THAT YOU
ARE HOPING TO GET TO TWENTY?
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE A YEAR
SO IS THERE HOW DO YOU
COORDINATE THAT YEAH THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION AFFECT I GUESS
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AT MISTER
COUNSEL BE ON THE NEXT PANEL
COULD PROBABLY GOING TO EVEN
MORE DEATH THAN I CAN ON THAT
ONE BUT BROADLY SPEAKING. ALL OF
OUR FIGHTS WILL BE LICENSED BY
THE FEDERAL AVIATION
ADMINISTRATION ORGANISED
ACCOUNTS ON HIS PEERS IN.
IN THE OFFICE OF COMMERCIAL
SPACE TRANSPORTATION.
WHO WHO WILL GOVERN?
IT ESSENTIALLY EVERYTHING THAT
WE DO WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE.
GOING THROUGH ALL THE RIGHT
THAT.
PROCEDURES TO TO NOTIFY YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WE DO OPERATE TAKE
OFF FROM AN AIRPORT SO MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE PUTTING OUT THE
RIGHT NOTICE TO. AIRMEN ARE
NOTICES TO MARINERS OF GOING OUT
OVER THE WATER TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE.
TAKING THE RIGHT STEPS TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THE ON
INVOLVED PUBLIC AND OF HAVE
GOVERNMENT OR CIVILIAN PROPERTY
ANYWAY ANYWHERE NEAR OF OUR FOR
OUR FACILITIES. SO THAT'S THE
PRIMARY OFFICE THAT WE WORK WITH
WE YOU DO ALSO REQUIRE THINGS
LIKE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS FCC
LICENSING FOR THAT. FOR THE
RADIO FREQUENCIES THAT WERE
USING TO COMMUNICATE THAT NOW
KNOW A LICENSING FOR THE CAMERAS
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE ON BOARD THE
VEHICLE AS WELL BUT THE BULK OF
THE WORK WILL HAPPEN TO THE FAA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT CAN THE THE STATE? THE
STATE TO TO SUPPORT HER.
YOUR EXCITING ACTIVITIES IN IN
CALIFORNIA BOSS AND GENERAL WE
WE FEEL VERY VERY WELL
SUPPORTED.
A BUY OUT BY OUR INDIVIDUAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND BY THE
COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE SO AGAIN
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I THINK SOMETIMES BY THE
INHERENT NEWNESS OF WHAT WE ARE
DOING THERE IS ALWAYS QUESTION
MARKS AND UNCERTAINTY WE
OFTENTIMES RUN INTO SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE USE AN
AIRPLANE TO LAUNCH A ROCKET INTO
THERE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT KAY'S AT
AN AIRPLANE OR IS IT SPACES
DEMINT. HOW IS A TAXED AND HOW
THE OTHER A?
THE NICE THING IS THAT EVEN WHEN
IT'S CONFUSING WE'VE ALWAYS
FOUND THE ABILITY TO WORK IT IN
AND GREAT GOOD FAITH AND HAVE
FANTASTIC WORKING RELATIONS WITH
WITH ARE REGULATED WRITERS WITH
THAT WITH TAXATION OFFICIALS
EVERYONE ELSE AT AT LOCAL STATE.
COUNTY AND AND FEDERAL LEVELS
AND THEIR SO EVEN WHEN ISSUES
ARE HARD AND CONFUSING AND BURKE
WERE GETTING THEM GETTING THE
WORK DONE THE WORK WELL. I WOULD
SAY THE CONTINUING THEME ABOUT
AND THIS ALIGNS WELL WITH THAT
WITH THAT WITH LEGISLATION THAT
YOU'VE PASSED IN AND AND OTHERS
THAT ARE UNDER CONSIDERATION NOW
IS JUST MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
AN OPEN DIALOGUE.
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE SOME
UNKNOWN UNKNOWNS IN THE FUTURE
FOR EVERYONE OF THESE COMPANIES
I AM SURE.
AND THERE WILL BE.
REGULATIONS ARE WRITTEN NOT
ANTICIPATING SOME WILD IDEA THAT
AN ENTREPRENEUR IS GOING TO WALK
INTO MISTER CASES OUT HIS WITH
OFFICE WITHIN THE NEAR FUTURE.
AND SUGGESTED SO HAVING THAT
ABILITY I'M TO ADD TO IT TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THAT TO
DISTINGUISH MEMBERS AND MEMBERS
OF STAFF.
IN SESSIONS LIKE THIS IN AN
OTHERWISE IS IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL AND AND I I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR FURRIER AT
PROGRESS IN THAT STATE.
THANK YOU.
WHAT DO YOU USE ANY OF THE?
MATERIALS FROM HYDRO FLOW OR
FROM.
ALCOA BECAUSE THEY'RE BOTH IN
MY DISTRICT AFFILIATED
HYDROPHONES WRITTEN THERE THE
FAMILY ON BUT I KNOW THEY DO THE
PIPING. AND ALCOA DOES ALL THE
BOLTS.
.
THEY SAY THAT FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS THERE'S TWO SITES IN
FULLERTON.
I BELIEVE IN A LITTLE PLUG YES I
BELIEVE THE ANSWER IS YES BUT IF
I MAY PERHAPS ALL TAKEN OUT AND
THEN WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU SO SO
I CAN CONFIRM FOR CERTAIN.
RIGHT MISTER LACKEY.
WELL OBVIOUSLY I HAD THE GREAT
PRIVILEGE OF.
.
DURING THE FACILITIES AND WE'RE
VERY VERY PROUD OF.
THE PROGRESS YOU GUYS HAVE MADE
AND.
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PARTNER TO.
THE STILL TAKE YOUR SUCCESS.
AND NOT BE AN IMPEDIMENT AND
SOMETIMES THAT CAN BE A BIGGER
CHALLENGE THAN.
BOTH OF US CAN CONTROL.
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOU
TAKING THE TIME TO COME AND
VISIT US AND ALL THE HELP THAT
YOU YOU HAVE GIVEN US.
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE MISTER
POMERANTZ THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE INVITATION.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST FOR PANEL
NUMBER ONE SEAN CASEY THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE SILICON
VALLEY SPACE CENTER.
WELCOME SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ME.
LOOK FOR RISEN TATIAN HERE
.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR INVITING
ME.
UP TO PRESENT TODAY AND ALSO
LIKE TO.
THANK.
A USER FOR INCLUDING.
OUR GROUP OF MORE THAN
CALIFORNIAN.
START UPS IN THIS PROCESS.
I PERSONALLY FEEL THAT WE HAVE
A GROWING MOMENTUM OF EARLY
STAGE COMPANIES IN THE BAY AREA.
AND OF THAT.
THEIR REPRESENTATION IS
IMPORTANT. TO THIS PROCESS OF A
PREPARED STATEMENT HERE WHICH
I'D LIKE TO READ AND GO TO SOME
SLIDES. TALKING ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY.
THOM MY NAME IS SEAN CASEY I'M
I'M.
SERVE SEVERAL ROLES ONE OF
WHICH IS I HEAD OF THE SILICON
VALLEY SPACE ON OUR WHICH IS AN
INCUBATOR AND ACCELERATOR FOR
EARLY STAGE COMPANIES.
IN THE SPACE SECTOR PRIOR TO
SELL VALLEY SPACE CENTER I
SPENT.
FIFTEEN PLUSYEARS WORKING AT
NASA AMES ON THE AIRBORNE
ASTRONOMY PROGRAM MY
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND IS AS AN
AIRBORNE ASTRONOMER HAVING BEEN
AT NASA GODDARD AND ALSO AT NASA
AMES. SOPHIA THE STRATOSPHERIC
OBSERVATORY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
ME IS NOW BASED IN PALMDALE AND
SO I'VE HAD DONE.
HAD THE PLEASURE OF GETTING
DOWN THERE AND KNOWING SOME OF
OUR.
AEROSPACE COLLEAGUES IN THAT
AREA ASIDE FROM BEING UP HERE.
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE NEW SPACE INDUSTRY WHICH IS
LOCALLY WHAT PEOPLE REFER TO AS
HARTMAN ORIEL SPACE WE SEE A LOT
OF PRESS ASSOCIATED WITH.
SOME OF THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
PRESENTED TO A PREVIOUSLY SPACEX
AND VIRGIN GALACTIC  ALSO
THEIR SUB BLUE ORIGIN. AND.
STRADDLE LAUNCH ON THEM.
I FEEL THAT THERE IS AN EMPHASIS
ON WHAT QUOTE BILLIONAIRES ARE
DOING IN THIS INDUSTRY.
WITH LESS OF AN EMPHASIS ON A
WHAT SMALLER MERE MORTAL
ENTREPRENEURS ARE DOING I THINK
THE SPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
DEPENDS UPON. THOSE OF NAM LET A
LESS MONEY TO INDIVIDUALS. AND
THEIR ROLE TO FUNCTION IN OUR
SILICON VALLEY SOCIETY A WHICH
WE'VE KNOWN.
IS VERY POPULAR FOR GOOGLE ONE
FAKE FACEBOOK IN AND SOME OF
THOSE COMPANIES.
I ALSO ASK.
ARE NGUYEN TWO ONE. OUR SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE SOME REPORTS
THAT I'VE RUN ACROSS CENTER FROM
GOLDMAN SACHS OF THE BRYCE.
DONE.
OF THE BRYCE GROUP AND.
SPACE ANGELS ABOUT THE GROWTH
OF THE NEW SPACE INDUSTRY I SENT
THESE TWO ARE WHEN THIS MORNING
SO THEY MADE UP IN YOUR PACKETS.
TODAY BUT I THINK THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW THE
INDUSTRY IS GROWING.
I HAVE.
ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE COMMERCIAL
SPACEFLIGHT FEDERATION IN
WASHINGTON DC. AND THEY HAVE FOR
IN THAT CAPACITY TRAVELED AROUND
THE COUNTRY TALKING TO A VARIETY
OF GROUPS IN FLORIDA AND TEXAS
AND NEW YORK. AND.
OTHER STATES AND I SEE A
GROWING MOMENTUM OF SPACE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP NOT JUST HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT ELSEWHERE.
A ONE OF THE SLIDES UP LIKE TO
PRESENT IS.
AID FUNNY DIAGRAM OF VENTURE
CAPITAL.
AS ITS A ALLOCATED INTO THIS
SECTOR THERE ARE SEVERAL.
.
GOT A BIG HIGH POINTS
OF FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
GENERALLY BETWEEN.
LE TWO THOUSAND FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. YOU SEEN
OUR A BUBBLING OF INTEREST
WITHIN THE VENTURE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY.
PROBABLY MAXING OUT ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION PER YEAR
OSCILLATING IT BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED TO FIVE HUNDRED BUT IN
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
WE'VE SEEN BANNER YEARS FOR
VENTURE CAPITAL INVESTMENT.
SOME OF THOSE NUMBERS ARE
DOMINATED BY.
COMPANIES LIKE SPACEX AND.
ONE WEB.
BUT WHAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN IS A
GROWING INTEREST AND.
THE SMALLER START UPS OF WHICH
HER ROUTE WHICH ARE SHOWN HERE
AND CERTAINLY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE'VE SEEN
A GROWTH OF THOSE.
FUNDING FOR SMALLER SIR.
SMALLER START UPS.
NUMBER ONE WEB IS A CONSOLATION
OF OVER EIGHT HUNDRED SATELLITES
THAT ARE POISED TO PROVIDE
GLOBAL INTERNET COVERAGE AND
INDEED THE GROWTH THAT YOU SPACE
INDUSTRY MAY HANG UPON THE
SUCCESS OF. ONE WEB AND SOME
OTHER COMPANIES.
.
I WOULD NOTE THAT.
THE ONE WEB CONSOLATION IS
ACTUALLY A CONCEIVED OF HEARING
CALIFORNIA WHEREAS THE SATELLITE
CONSTRUCTION IS ACTUALLY MOVING
DOWN TO.
DOING THAT MOVING DOWN TO
FLORIDA FOR THAT CONSOLATION.
THAT TECHNOLOGIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPORTANT IN THIS GROWING
NEW SPACE SECTOR ARE THE SAME
TECHNOLOGIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISRUPTING A WIDE VARIETY. OF OF
INDUSTRIES THIS IS REPORT FROM
TWENTY THIRTEEN FROM MACKENZIE.
TALKING ABOUT DUH DISRUPTIVE
TECHNOLOGIES AND I LISTS THOSE
HERE BECAUSE WE SEE THOSE SAME
THINGS APPLY TO THE SMALL
SATELLITE SECTOR. IN PARTICULAR.
MOBILE.
COMPUTING TECHNOLOGIES MOBILE
COMMUNICATIONS.
THE ABILITY OF A AYE AND.
ROBOTICS ALONG WITH ADDITIVE
MANUFACTURING AND.
SOLAR PANEL COME.
IMPROVEMENTS AND EFFICIENCY.
SO A GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW THAT IS
IMPACTING OUR INDUSTRY IS WITH
THE COMPANY.
ONE OF THE EARLIEST.
SPACE STARTUPS CALLED PLANET
LANDS  IT'S NOW CALLED PLANET
AND I SHOW HERE.
SOME OF THE FOUNDERS NAM.
I'M AND WILL MARSHALL AND A
CHRIS WELLHAUSEN WITH THOSE
STEVE JURVETSON AN ANGEL
INVESTOR AND VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTOR. HOW THAT'S WELL KNOWN
HERE IN SILICON VALLEY OF STEVE
IS ACTUALLY HOLDING ONE OF THE
EARLY DOVE SATELLITES WHICH IS A
CUBE SET TECHNOLOGY BASED UPON A
CONCEPT DEVELOPED BY?
TILE RESEARCH FACULTY WELL BOB
TWIGS AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY.
THIS TECHNOLOGY PRETTY MUCH
BEEN AROUND FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS PRIOR TO.
.
SPACE AS PRIOR TO PLANETS
ADOPTION BUT.
BOTH WILL AND CHRIS WORKING AT
NASA AMES WERE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH P. WHARTON'S VISION OF
SMALL SATELLITES AS THEY APPLY
TO THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY.
SO CHRIS AND WILL.
AND OTHERS SPUN OUT OF NASA
AMES TO FORM PLANET AND.
THERE WAS A GREAT DEAL OF
UNCERTAINTY AND CONSTERNATION
ABOUT THE UTILITY OF SMALL
SATELLITES ON HIM LOW WORTH
ORBIT. THE FACT THAT YOU'RE IN
LOW EARTH ORBIT MEANS THAT YOU
HAVE A BENIGN RADIATION AND.
AND THAT ALLOWS YOU TO USE WHAT
ARE TERRESTRIAL TECHNOLOGIES
UMMAH IN THAT.
ON IN IT AT THAT AT THOSE
ALTITUDES.
SO.
MAHOOD PLANET.
INITIALLY FLEW A A FEW
SATELLITES AND TODAY HAS GROWN
TO OVER TWO HUNDRED SATELLITES
IN LOW EARTH ORBIT THAT PROVIDE
A TWICE DAILY SNAPSHOT. OF OF
THE PLANET AS AN ASTRONOMER I
KNOW THAT EVERY TIME YOU BUILD A
NEW OBSERVATIONAL FACILITY
YOU'RE GOING TO DERIVE NEW
RESULTS. AND.
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHATEVER WE HAPPEN TO BE
OBSERVING IN THIS CASE OF ITS
THE EARTH. OF PLANET ALLIES ALSO
LEVERAGE TO GROWING SUPPLY
CHAIN.
AND WITH SECONDARY LAUNCH
CAPABILITIES ON VEHICLES LIKE
SPACEX AND OTHERS THREE ABLE TO
DEPLOY THE SATELLITES IN LOW
EARTH ORBIT I SHOW HERE THE
SATELLITES BEING DEPLOYED FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
WHICH WAS A RELATIVELY NOVEL.
CONCEPT AND PIONEERED BY THE
SMALL SATELLITE COMMUNITY HERE
AND IT'S HIGHER PAYLOAD OF SMALL
SATELLITES OR SHIPPED UP TO THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION. AND
THEN DEPLOYED BY ASTRONAUTS ON A
BOOM SHOWN HERE A COMPANY CALLED
NARAL RACKS ACTUALLY OF. SERVES
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
AND THE SMALL SATELLITE
COMMUNITY FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF
SATELLITES IN LOWER THOR AND
LOWER EARTH ORBIT.
THE SATELLITES AS YOU CAN SEE BY
WITH STEVE ARE ABOUT THE SIZE OF
A BREAD BOX.
THIS IS.
THAT TECHNOLOGIES ABLE
DEVELOPED AT A PRICE POINT WHICH
IS AMENABLE TO VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH NEW
SPACE.
IS NOT THAT VENTURE CAPITALISTS
HAVE EMBRACED SPACE IT'S THAT
SPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP HAS MOVED
INTO THE FUNDING ENVELOPE WHICH
IS TYPICAL OF A SILICON VALLEY
STARTUP. WITH A SEED ROUND
SERIES A SERIES PAYS CERES CITY
AT. YOU KNOW SAY HALF MILLION
DOLLARS ONE AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE.
A. A TECHNOLOGY MILESTONES AND
MARKET RETIRED AND RETIRE MARKET
RISK.
NUMBER WHILE THEY'RE TAKING
INTRODUCTIONS OF CHARGES OF
FUNDING.
AN EXAMPLE OF.
.
PLANETS HOA ENABLED CAPABILITY
THESE DAYS IMPLANTED THOSE ALSO
GONE TO REMOTE OF ACQUIRING AND
THE GROWTH OF THE COMPANY. FROM
ITS START IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
TO TODAY HAS PULLED IN ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THEY'VE
DEVELOPED OR SMALL SATELLITE
PROGRAM AND THEY'VE ALSO
ACQUIRED SOME ADDITIONAL
SATELLITE FACILITIES.
THIS IS A IN ANIMATION THAT
GONNA.
I HOPE THIS COMES UP HERE.
BUT WHEN THE WIND IT BACK.
A SERIES OF IMAGES TAKEN WITH
THE PLANET CAPE HOA PLANET
FACILITIES.
OVER A PERIOD OF MONTHS.
SHOWING THE BUILD OUT OF.
THE CAST WOULD GET A FACTORY.
THE DATA.
THAT YOU GET FROM THESE
PROGRAMS.
I'M.
LET'S.
THE DATA FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
.
ASSISTS BOAT CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
FRIES ON THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY AGRICULTURE MINING.
FINANCE
ON I OF A NUMBER OF OTHER
EXAMPLES WHICH FOR THE. BREVITY
OF THIS PRESENTATION I HAVE NOT
INCLUDED. BUT SATELLITE IMAGING
ALLOWS YOU TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY
INTO OUR ECONOMY.
UNLIKE WHAT WE'VE HAD BEFORE I
HAD A A NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
LEVEL IT ALSO ALLOWS US
TRANSPARENCY INTO ECONOMIES
WHERE. A WE MIGHT NOT HAVE THAT
KIND OF TRANSPARENCY WHAT IS THE
OIL USE AND.
IN.
I CHINA OR CALL USE IN ERA IN
INDIA.
PLANET O. WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE SMALL SATELLITE PROGRAM
HAS ACTUALLY PIONEERED A THE USE
OF THESE THESE TECHNOLOGIES FOR
A WIDE VARIETY OF OTHER FIRMS.
MANY OF WHICH YOU'RE HERE IN
THE.
IN THE BAY AREA.
COMPANIES.
THAT I'VE LISTED HERE.
FOR EMERGING COMPANIES OUR
PLANET AND ASTRA DIGITAL AND
SADDLE LOGIC THEY'RE ALL LOOKING
AT UNIQUE VERTICALS NOT TO SERVE
IN MARKETS. OF AGRICULTURE AND
VIDEO A SYNTHETIC APERTURE RADAR
DATA IS BEING DONE BY CAPELLA
SPACE. THERE ARE TECHNOLOGIES
WHICH SHOW PROMISE IN SPACE
WHICH HAVEN'T BEEN FLOWN THAT
ARE BEING FLOWN A.
I DEVELOPED BY ENTREPRENEURS A
COMMUNICATION COMPANIES LIKE
AUDACITY AND STRATUS.
GPS OCCULTATION COMPANIES LIKE
SPIRE WE'RE ABLE TO MEASURE.
PERHAPS PROPERTIES AT THE END
BURSTS ATMOSPHERE.
AND.
DATA ANALYSIS COMPANIES
COMPANIES THAT.
DO NOT ACTUALLY HAVE HARDWARE
BETTER USING THE DATA THAT COMES
FROM OTHER SATELLITE COMPANIES
AND MAKING THAT LAST MARK THAT
LAST MILE PLAY.
.
TO.
TO CUSTOMERS.
SPACE DEBRIS FROM LEO LABS AND
MADE THE SPACE FOCUSING ON ON
ORBIT FIBER IN IT MANUFACTURING.
I THINK MADE IN SPACE IS A
UNIQUE COMPANY BECAUSE IT'S
ACTUALLY PIONEERED ITS
TECHNOLOGY USING SUBORBITAL
FLIGHTS OF BEFORE DEPLOYING TO
THE INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
THE FIBER THAT THE PLANNING ON
MAKING.
HAS THE BENEFIT OF BEING HIGH
THROUGHPUT. AND.
LOW ABSORPTION COEFFICIENTS TO
ENABLE BROAD SPECTRUM AND THEN
HIGH DATA RATES UNLIKE A WHAT
WE'VE SEEN PREVIOUSLY.
A WHEN I LOOK AT VEHICLES LIKE
VIRGIN GALACTIC AND THEIR USE IS
A RESEARCH PLATFORM NOT ONLY IS
IT. JUST FOR A TOURISTS AND
EDUCATORS BUT FOR PDB PLAY
MAIDEN SPACE DID ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED PARABOLAS ON THE ZERO G.
VEHICLE TO PROVE OUT FOR THREE
D. PRINTING TECHNOLOGY. THIS WAS
AN IMPORTANT USE OF THAT VEHICLE
BEFORE GOING TO THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION.
WITH THIS WE EXPECT TO SEE A
WIDE VARIETY. OF.
SMALL SATELLITE GUN COMPANIES
AS I'VE SHOWN IN THE LAST SLIDE
I WOULD SAY OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS IS PROJECTED DOUBLE SEE
ABOUT A THREE X. INCREASE. IN
SMALL SATELLITES IN LOW EARTH
ORBIT.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF INCUBATORS
AND ACCELERATORS FOR INSTANCE
THE FOUNDERS INSTITUTE. OF HAS
THEIR STAR FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
THAT EXPECTS TO GRADUATE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED.
NEW SPACE START UPS.
OVER THE NEXT.
SEVEN YEARS THIS IS IDEA RESI
THE FOUNDER OF FOUNDER THE
FOUNDER OF FOUNDERS INSTITUTE OF
SPEAKING WITH STEVE JURVETSON
ONE OF THE EARLY INVESTORS. IN
PLANET LABS.
ALL OF THE COMPANIES THAT I'VE
LISTED PREVIOUSLY OUR EARLY SEED
STAGE SERIES A SERIES B..
COMPANIES.
YES MA'AM.
SO IT KIND OF GOES BACK TO THE
QUESTION I ASKED YOU ABOUT. OF
RIGHT NOW THERE'S SOMEONE A
MINIMAL.
TRAFFIC IF YOU WANT TO SAY IT.
I. YOU SAID NINE THE MENU OR
EXPECT INTO. YOU KNOW REALLY
INCREASE THAT WITH WHAT ALL THE
OTHER START UPS AND SO FORTH
RIGHT FIVE YEARS FROM NOW HOW
ARE WE LOOKING AT MANAGING THAT
IN WHO WOULD MANAGE THEM I MEAN
I SORT OF IN THE FEDERAL BUDGET
WITH OTHER. GLOBALLY HOW DO YOU
MANAGE THAT THE SKINNY MANAGED
COME.
.
THROUGH OUR WORK WITH THE FAA
YES.
THIS ISN'T WHERE WE ARE TODAY
IN SPACES MUCH LIKE WHERE WE
WERE IN AVIATION.
LET'S SAY AROUND NINETEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN THIRTY THERE'S A GREAT
BOOK BY CHARLES LYNN BOOK ABOUT
CHARLES WENT BEHIND HIM.
AND RURAL LIMBURG ON NORTH TO
THE ORIENT THAT TALKS ABOUT
CHARLES LINDBERGH. NORTH TO THE
ORIENT.
.
WHICH IS A GREAT BOOK BECAUSE.
IT'S WHILE THE LINDBERGH BABY
WAS STILL ALIVE BUT IT'S A.
WITH AMARO FLYING AS THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND NAVIGATOR
WITH CHARLES LINDBERGH AS HE
FLIES FROM NEW YORK A TO THE
ORIENT LOOKING FOR ROUTES FOR
PAN AM.
AVIATION IN THE NINETEEN.
THIRTIES WAS IN A VERY PRIMITIVE
STATE TODAY WITH AVIATION NOT
ONLY ARE WE ABLE TO A FIELD.
.
DON'T TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AIRCRAFT IN THE AIR
SIMULTANEOUSLY WE'VE ALSO WORKED
ON TECHNOLOGY THAT ALLOWS THE
SEPARATION OF AIRCRAFT TO GO
FROM TWO THOUSAND FEET DOWN TO
ONE THOUSAND WAS THE RACE TO.
THE MOON AND
SO FORTH. AND COMPETITION.
AMONGST OTHER COUNTRIES.
DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING ARE
OPEN I MEAN ARE WE FAR AHEAD OF
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THAT SENSES
OF. SPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS
NOW BECOMING GLOBAL FUND.
THAT DUMB YES COMPANIES LIKE
PLANET LASSEN SKYBOX GOT THEIR
START HERE IN SILICON VALLEY.
BUT I'M WERE SEEN A INVESTMENT
FUNDS IN THE UK IN EUROPE A IN
ASIA ENTREPRENEURS.
.
SEEN THE ADVANTAGE OF DEPLOYING
THEIR ASSETS IN LOW EARTH ORBIT
HOW WE MANAGE ALL THAT IS GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE A FOR THE.
FOR THE FAA THERE CERTAINLY
REQUIREMENTS
ON THE HOOD DE ORBITING OF
SATELLITES. OF AND YOU KNOW WITH
RENTAL LOWERED ALTITUDE THEN THE
SATELLITES NO NATURALLY DE ORBIT
AS YOU GET HIGHER UP THAN THE
LIFETIME FOR SATELLITE TO.
SATELLITE INCREASES THERE ARE
COMPANIES ON LIKE ASTRO SCALE
WHICH IS PULLED IN I BELIEVE
ABOUT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
FROM JAPANESE AND FROM JAPANESE
IN SINGAPORE INVESTORS TO MANAGE
THE SPACE DEBRIS PROBLEM. LEO
LABS IS A COMPANY BASED HERE AND
SILICON VALLEY OUT OF THE
STANFORD RESEARCH INSTITUTE.
WHICH IS TO PROVIDE NEXT
GENERATION.
A SITUATIONAL AWARENESS ON
SPACE DEBRIS IN THE AND LOWER
EARTH ORBIT YES THIS IS A
CHALLENGING ISSUE AND WITH A
COMPANY LIKE ONE WEB PLANNING TO
DEPLOY NEARLY A THOUSAND
SATELLITES AND THEY'RE NOT THE
ONLY ONE.
IT'S GOING TO BE A MOM MORE OF
AN ISSUE AT THE.
AT THE FEDERAL AND GLOBAL LEVEL.
THANK YOU SO. I'M AND IN
WRAPPING THIS UP I WOULD SAY IS.
THAT ENTREPRENEURS ARE FOCUS
NOT JUST ON LOWER EARTH ORBIT
AND WORK ON THE INTERNATIONAL
SPACE STATION BUT ALSO WITH A
RETURN TO THE MOON THIS IS BOB
RICHARDS FOR MODE EXPRESS. WHO I
HAD AS OFFICE OUT IN NAM MOFFETT
FIELD I SENSE MOVED ALSO?
TO FLORIDA.
AND.
IT BOB IS ONE OF THE LEADERS IN
WHAT WAS THE GOAL IN IRAQ'S
PRICE.
IN NOT DEPLOYING THEIR MISSION
A TO THE MOTOR NAY EXPECT MANY
OF THESE GROUPS WHETHER IT'S BOB
OF FROM MOON EXPRESS. OF THE
PART TIME SCIENTISTS OUT OF
GERMANY TEAM INDICE ADDED INDIA
SPACE AYE ELL ADDED ISRAEL WILL
MAKE AN ATTEMPT ON IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WE'VE ALSO.
JUST THE OTHER DAY HAD THE.
NASA LUNAR WORKSHOP WHERE NASA
IS INTERESTED IN CONTRACTING
WITH PRIVATE COMPANIES.
TO DELIVER PAYLOADS.
TO THE MOON OUR NASA AMES
RESEARCH CENTER IS VERY ACTIVE
IN THE EAST.
DEVELOPMENT OF PILLOWS WITH A
BROAD SCIENCE COMMUNITY AND.
THEY'RE ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
THIS ENTREPRENEURIAL THE WHAT
ARE WITH ENTREPRENEURS LIKE
MASTIN SPACE SYSTEMS WHICH IS
DOWN A MOJAVE. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF.
MISSIONS OF. CAO FOR LUNAR
ACTIVITY.
IN CLOSING I WOULD SAY THAT.
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES I'VE
SEEN A WIDE VARIETY OF STATE.
ACTIVITIES WITH REGARD TO SPACE
SOME OF THEM ARE VERY ACTIVE
LIKE GOV OF A SPACE FLORIDA
WHICH WAS IN A POSITION WHAT'S A
CANCEL THE SHUTTLE OF WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO. WITH IDEA ARE
TOTALLY UNDER PLAYED A WORKFORCE
BUT SPACE FLORIDA HAS REALLY
BEEN A VERY INTERESTING MODEL
FOR.
ENGAGING AND LEADING A SPACE
COMMUNITY THIS IS ALSO.
TAKEN PLACE IN COLORADO
COLORADO HAS A VERY NICELY
WRITTEN REPORT ABOUT DATA WHAT
THEIR ROAD. IS TOUGH FOR SPACE
FOR THAT STATE A KENTUCKY SPACE
HAS BEEN VERY ACTIVE. LA I LIKE
TO THINK OF RANKING OF STATES IN
GDP FROM CALIFORNIA NUMBER ONE
DOWN TO VERMONT NUMBER FIFTY
RECENTLY I MET A COMPANY.
FOUNDED IN VERMONT THAT WAS
MEETING WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
VERMONT TO.
ENCOURAGED AND TO STAY IN THE
STATE. KENTUCKY SPACES A GREAT
EXAMPLE LED BY CHRIS CAMPBELL OF
OF.
OF HOW THEY'VE EMBRACED BOTH
SMALL SATELLITES AND WORK ON THE
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION BOB
TWIGS WHO IS THE FOUNDER OF
CUBESATS HERE AT STANFORD ENDED
UP AT MOORHEAD STATE UNIVERSITY.
DOWN AND NON DOWN IN KENTUCKY
NEW YORK SPACE ALLIANCE IS ALSO
WORKING WITH CITY AND STATE
OFFICIALS AND SPACE COM IS
EVENT.
OUT OF.
OUT OF HOUSTON TEXAS HEARING
CALIFORNIA WAS A VERY ACTIVE
FOLLOWER WHILE I WAS ON THE
SOVIET PROGRAM OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPACE AUTHORITY.
BUT I FEEL THAT THAT.
THAT ORGANIZATION UP PERHAPS
AND WAS PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT
TIME BECAUSE AT THAT TIME WE
REALLY DIDN'T HAVE A GROWING
SPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP. UP
EFFORT I DO BELIEVE THAT A. ON
THIS COMMISSION SHOULD PAY
PROPER ATTENTION TO THE GROWING.
SPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP SECTOR
WHICH IS UNIQUELY CALIFORNIA YOU
MAY ASK WHY PEOPLE COME TO
CALIFORNIA FOR START UPS AND YOU
KNOW IT'S A SIMPLE ANSWER I
FORGET WHO WAS YOU KNOW WHY HE
ROBBED BANKS. BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE MONEY IS YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHERE THE MONEY IS AND
SILICON VALLEY BUT SILICON
VALLEY LEADS IF YOU'LL LOOK AT
THE PRICE WATERHOUSE REPORT
SILICON VALLEY CALIFORNIA LEADS.
IN VENTURE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
BUT NOT FAR BEHIND OUR STATES
LIKE HOME.
OF MASSACHUSETTS TEXAS COLORADO.
ENDA AND DAD NEW YORK TRISTATE
DATA TRISTATE AREA SO WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A LEAD IN THIS
AND SILICON VALLEY IS. YOUR
CONTINUES TO GAIN A GROWING
PERCENTAGE OF FILE OF A MONIES
FROM LIMITED PARTNERS BUT I FEEL
THAT THIS COMMISSION. IS VERY
IMPORTANT UP TO PROVIDE A JOINT
VISION FOR THE STATE.
YOU CAN LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AROUND THE GLOBE
WHETHER IT'S IN LUXEMBOURG OR
SINGAPORE. ALL YOU SEE.
A COUNTRIES ARE LOOKING TO BE
ACTIVE PLAYERS IN SPACE I THINK
IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO DECIDE
WHAT SHOULD WE DO IS TODAY THE
RIGHT TIME TO DO SOMETHING
TOMORROW.
BUT DATA IT CERTAINLY IS HARM A.
A GROWING PHENOMENON.
DATA WELL WE NEED TO KNOW AND
PAY ATTENTION TO SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
S. M. QUESTION.
IS THAT COMMISSION ACTIVE AND
DO THEY MEET INDEED ARE YOU ABLE
TO BE PARTICIPATE IN THAT AS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THEM I BILL.
OF THE AEROSPACE COMMISSION OKAY
SO.
MISTER CASEY WAS ONE OF THE
SUPPORTING WITNESSES AND WE WERE
JUST IN FRONT OF THE THE SENATE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE.
AND WE WERE AND IN FRONT OF
YOUR COMMITTEE EARLIER IN THE.
LAST YEAR. BUT.
WE DO HAVE A.
.
AS PART OF A TRYING TO ACHIEVE
A.
DIVERSE REPRESENTATION OF THE
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
INDUSTRIES A.
POSITION.
DESIGNATED FOR.
THE.
AEROSPACE ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
SUMMON THE IN THE AREA OF. THE
INCUBATORS AND ACCELERATORS TO
BE REPRESENTED ON AND AND I'D
LIKE I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY AMENDMENT UP TO
WHAT WAS AN EARLIER VERSION OF
THIS LEGISLATION.
ALONG THOSE ALONG THOSE LINES SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU KNOW I
I HAD TO STEP OUT TO. MEET WITH
SIMS NOW CONSTITUENTS BUTTER.
NAM.
I'D LIKE TO ASK OF IT HASN'T
BEEN ASKED ALREADY.
WHAT?
?
WHAT ARE THE PARTICULAR
CHALLENGES AND OBSTACLES TO?
THE VENTURE CAPITAL FINANCING
MODEL.
FOR AEROSPACE AS COMPARED TO
OTHER HIGH TECH INDUSTRY.
.
I THINK.
THERE'S A CHANCE THEY'RE
CERTAINLY CHALLENGES FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS AND AS I'VE PULLED.
SOME OF THE.
THAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS ALL I
CAN REALLY REPORT ON IS WHAT I
WOULD TERM AS AN ANECDOTAL. A
DATA.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY SOME GLOBAL
ISSUES THAT EVERYONE FEELS
HEARING CALIFORNIA ON.
TURNED HOUSING COSTS AND.
AND TAXATION AND CORPORATE
TAXES ARE CERTAINLY HR A ISSUES
HR LAWS.
BETTER.
THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR.
WORKPLACE AND TREATMENT OF
CONTRACTORS.
.
AND RULES AND REGULATIONS THAT
APPLY TO RULES AND REGULATIONS
SUCH AS SUPPLY TO THE SMALL
BUSINESSES I FEEL. THAT.
THOSE MAYBE THINGS THAT JUST
APPLY ACROSS THE BOARD ON THIS
END IF WERE FOCUSED SOLELY ON
LARGE AEROSPACE COMPANIES WE MAY
NOT APPRECIATE THE COSTS. OF
THOSE REGULATIONS ON SMALLER
RUSSIA SMALLER COMPANIES.
I BELIEVE I'M A STILL WORKING
WITH THE VENTURE CAPITAL
INDUSTRY THEY WERE VERY
INTERESTED. IN.
IN THIS BILL AND THE
LEGISLATION WE HAD WE REACHED
OUT TO ABOUT A HUNDRED A
DIFFERENT VENTURE FUNDS AND HAD
THEIR FEEDBACK AND I THINK THERE
BEALL WILLING TO.
CONTRIBUTE SO OF IF YOU'D LIKE
I CAN.
HAD.
A MODEST AMOUNT OF TIME IN
RESPONDING TO.
THE LEGISLATION AND.
I'M BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS FOR THINGS IN
SPECIFIC THAT PEOPLE LIKE RIGHT
NOW ALL I HAVE PURCHASED
ANECDOTAL.
COMMENTS FROM INDIVIDUALS WHICH
I DON'T AS A SCIENTIST I DON'T
FEEL THAT THAT'S. PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL I FEEL THAT THIS
COMMISSION CAN COME UP WITH A
SYSTEMATIC UNDERSTANDING OF
WHERE WE ARE. A AS AN INDUSTRY
AND WHAT VARIOUS GROUPS ARE ARE
ARE LOOKING FOR OKAY.
A AYE AND PERHAPS I. CAN STAY
MY QUESTION NO. A BETTER BUT.
YOU KNOW AND UNTIL RECENTLY
WHEN I WHEN I STARTED MEETING
WITH AEROSPACE A.
ACCELERATORS IN IN INCUBATORS.
.
MY.
EXPERIENCE HAD BEEN LIMITED TO
IN TERMS OF VENTURE CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS PRIMARILY WITH
SILICON VALLEY YOU KNOW.
COMPUTER SOFTWARE HARDWARE.
INTERNET RELATED TO.
ACTIVITIES AND SO I WASN'T AS
FAMILIAR WITH.
THE US.
THIS KIND OF ENTREPRENEURIAL
MODEL.
TAKING PLACE IN THE AEROSPACE
INDUSTRY AND AND DIE I THINK I
TOLD YOU. THAT IF IT WAS A.
REFRESHING.
CHANGE FOR ME BECAUSE MY PRIOR
EXPERIENCE WITH.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE MAJOR
AEROSPACE COMPANIES THAT THEY'D
THEY TEND TO BE.
YOU KNOW RELY HEAVILY ON THE
DEFENSE CONTRACTS AND AND. YOU
THEY'RE MUCH MORE.
.
YOU KNOW FOCUSED ON.
INTERVIEW THE THEY THEY TEND TO
BE MUCH MORE CONSERVATIVE IN
TERMS OF. OF.
YOU KNOW.
MAKING SURE THAT THERE
STRENGTHENING THEIR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE
IN A LOT OF FORMER MILITARY
OFFICERS WHO HAD WORKED IN THE
PENTAGON TO HELP THEM.
YOU KNOW.
BY.
YOU KNOW CONTINUE THAT THAT
PIPELINE OF FINANCING THAT HAVE
BEEN PRIMARILY COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IT'S IT'S SO
TO SEE. AEROSPACE COMPANIES
TALKING ABOUT ANGEL INVESTORS
AND AND.
AND AND SEED CAPITAL AND YOU
KNOW.
IT'S.
I THINK THERE'RE YOUNG IT AT ME
THERE ARE A TO AFFECTS ONE OF
WHICH.
THAT I MENTIONED IS THAT UP
VENTURE CAPITAL RULES DO NOT
CHANGED I WAS AT SOME OF BAD
THEY SAID OH WELL WE THINK
VENTURE CAPITALISTS ARE RELAXING
THERE ARE.
Y. REQUIREMENTS FOR. YOU KNOW
SPACES LIKE THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
NOT THE CASE
THE.
DUE DILIGENCE THAT A COMPANY
HAS TO PASS WITH YOUR SOFTWARE
COMPANY OR SOCIAL NETWORKING
COMPANY HERE. ANY OTHER OUT YOU
KNOW AND AG COMPANY IS EXACTLY
THE SAME FOR.
TOUGH FOR SPACE AS IT WOULD BE
FOR A LITTLE ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
COMPANY ON THIS YEAH INVESTORS.
IF YOU'RE RUNNING A FIRM BICU
SAY THIS IS THE AREA THAT I'M
GOING AFTER YOU SELL THAT AREA
TO YOUR. YOU KNOW THIS INDUSTRY
THERE'S VERTICAL YOU SELL THAT
TO YOUR LIMITED PARTNERS IN
LIMITED PARTNERS HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY OF OPPORTUNITIES TO PICK
FROM WHETHER IT'S TODAY. A AYE A
SLEEPER ISSUE MIGHT BE QUANTUM
COMPUTING. HOME ADDITIVE
MANUFACTURING. SO WELL IT'S NOT
THAT VENTURE CAPITALISTS ARE
RELAXING THEIR REQUIREMENTS.
WHAT'S ALSO BUT WHAT'S HAPPENED
IS THAT.
SPACE COMPANIES EARLY STAGE HER
OUT IN A MERE MORTAL COMPANIES
HAVE NOW ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE
RETIREMENT OF RISK WITH.
INVESTMENT NUMBERS THAT MATCH
WHAT A TYPICAL ANGEL VENTURE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY
IS ABLE TO DO.
LAUNCH COMPANIES ARE
PARTICULARLY PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU NEED A
LARGE INVESTMENT OF CAPITAL ON
MR MOSK IS IN A VERY PRIVILEGED
POSITION BEING A FOUNDER OF
PAYPAL. ALSO HAD BEEN.
.
YOU KNOW THE ABILITY TO DO WHAT
I WOULD CALL A THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY AROUND.
A WITH HIS OTHER COFOUNDERS
PETER THIEL OTHERS SET UP AND SO
WHAT MUSK IS ABLE TO DO OR SAY.
RICHARD BRANSON WHEN HE GOES TO
THE ABU DHABI'S SOVEREIGN WEALTH
FUND THOSE A UNIQUE EXAMPLES.
BUT.
THE FACT THAT PETER PLOTS HER.
WITH SPIRE WAS ABLE TO RAISE A
MILLION DOLLARS ON IS RG SET
CONCEPT AND THEN PIVOT. TO WORK
ON.
GPS OCCULTATION MEASUREMENTS
AND I MY MIND BE THE FIRST ONE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT YOU COULD USE
SMALL SATELLITES TO MEASURE GPS
SIGNALS IN LOW EARTH ORBIT. AND
PETER HAS SUCCESSFULLY GROWN A
SPIRE TEMPLE IN WHAT WAS SEVENTY
MILLIONS WORTH SEVENTY MILLION
WITH A DOLLARS DEPLOY A
CONSOLATION.
IN LOWER EARTH ORBIT AND NOW WAS
PULLED IN ANOTHER SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS COME FROM LUXEMBOURG A
OR TO ESTABLISH A. YOU KNOW AN
OFFICER AND OFFICE OUT THERE.
SO. THE MODEL FOR SPACE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP HAS MATCHED THE
MODEL THAT WE'VE SEEN FOR OTHER
SILICON VALLEY.
START UPS BECAUSE OF LOW COST
THE TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE OF LAUNCH
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED BY SPACEX
IN VIRGINIA ANOTHER.
ALRIGHT.
FOR THE QUESTIONS NOW.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FIGURE MUCH.
NARRATOR AND PERHAPS IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE TO.
ALL THREE.
OF.
COULD DISPENSED FROM THE NEXT
PANEL TO TALK ABOUT TO.
INFRASTRUCTURE AND A LOOK IN
OTHER STATES AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE.
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE UP CORINA
ADRESE THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE MOJAVE AIR AND
SPACE PORT.
DAN GAVE THE END THAT I GALLON
THE PROGRAM MANAGER OF THE
HARRIS CORPORATION SPACEPORT
SYSTEMS.
AND SHERMAN COUNCIL AEROSPACE
ENGINEER UP FOR THE OFFICE OF
COMMERCIAL SPACE TRANSPORTATION.
BUT THE FEDERAL AVIATION
ADMINISTRATION.
WELCOME EVERYONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HELP US.
THE TABLE IS BIG ENOUGH.
WE'LL START WITH THE.
MYSTERIES FROM THE MOJAVE AIR
AND SPACE PORT.
EXCELLENT.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIRMAN. GOOD MORNING
ASSUMING LACKEY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY A I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT.
AFTER PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE HOT AIR AND
SPACE FOR LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES I THINK CALIFORNIA
HAS IN THIS INDUSTRY.
SO VERY BRIEFLY WE ARE A GENERAL
AVIATION AIRPORT AND SPACEPORT
WERE LOCATED ONE HUNDRED MILES
DIRECTLY NORTH OF LOS ANGELES IN
THE DESERT.
WE ARE A SPECIAL DISTRICT
AIRPORT IN WE ARE COMPLETELY
SELF CONTAINED WITH OPERATING
REVENUES WE GENERATE FROM OUR
CUSTOMERS.
MY HOBBY IS AN IDEAL PLACE FOR
THE COMMERCIAL SPACE INDUSTRY.
THERE ARE FEW PLACES IN THE
COUNTRY THAT PROVIDE THIS ONE
STOP SHOP FOR AIR CARRIER
OPERATIONS WHERE THEY CAN DESIGN
MANUFACTURE TEST.
FLIGHT TEST ROCKET TEST AND
OPERATE ALL IN ONE PLACE.
WE HAVE THE REMOTE LOCATION
IDEAL CLIMATE AND RESTRICTED
AIRSPACE NECESSARY FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS TO TEST AN OPERATE
SAFELY.
IN ADDITION TO THE TRADITIONAL
AEROSPACE COMPANIES SUCH AS
NORTHRUP GRUMMOND BE EIGHTY
SYSTEMS AND SCALED COMPOSITES
THAT ALL CALL MOJAVE HOME. TODAY
OUR NEW SPACE CUSTOMERS INCLUDE
VIRGIN GALACTIC THIS BISHOP
COMPANY VIRGIN ORBIT STRATA
LAUNCH AND MASTON SPACE SYSTEMS.
THESE ARE CUSTOMERS CURRENTLY
PAYING RENT IN MOJAVE.
NOT BECAUSE THEY RECEIVED AN
INCENTIVE BUT BECAUSE THAT IS
THE IDEAL PLACE FOR THEM TO
OPERATE.
BECAUSE WILL GIVE SUCH A GREAT.
O. OVERVIEW OF A VIRGIN I WON'T
GO INTO ANY OF THE DETAILS THE
ONLY THING I WILL ADD TO THAT IS
THE FACT THAT ALL THREE MERGING
COMPANIES ARE ARE. CURRENTLY
TENANTS OF MODERN SPACE PORT.
SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL DIDN'T
DIDN'T.
QUITE TOUCH ON WAS THE FACT
THAT VIRGIN GALACTIC HAS A LONG
STANDING AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE OF NEW MEXICO. NEW MEXICO
BILL THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR CUSTOM BUILT
FACILITY FOR VIRGIN GALACTIC.
WHICH STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX I BELIEVE TOOK FIVE YEARS TO
COMPLETE.
SO EVEN THOUGH VIRGIN GALACTIC
WILL BE MOVING TO NEW MEXICO
THIS BISHOP COMPANY WILL REMAIN
IN MOJAVE AND ROOTED IN MOJAVE.
STRUGGLE LAUNCH IS A COMPANY
FOUNDED BY PAUL ALLEN WHO IS ONE
OF THE FOUNDERS OF MICROSOFT
WHICH IS OF BUILDING THE WORLD'S
LARGEST AIRPLANE IN MOJAVE. IT
WILL BE CAPABLE OF LAUNCHING
VERY LARGE PAYLOADS INTO SPACE.
THE STRUGGLE WATCH AIRCRAFT IS
MANUFACTURED BY SKILLED
COMPOSITES WHICH IS ANOTHER
COMPANY WITH ROOTS IN MOJAVE.
AND THEY INTENDED TO CONDUCT
SPACE LAUNCHES FROM HOBBY AS
WELL.
SO REALLY WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
A MOJAVE IS PROVIDING AIRPORT
STYLE OPERATIONS FOR THE
COMMERCIAL SPACE COMPANIES THE
ONES THAT ARE USING AIR LAUNCH
METHOD TO OUR TO LAUNCH ROCKETS.
AND THEN JUST QUICKLY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
OH THERE IS RENEWED INTEREST IN
SPACE WOULD THEN NOT CONGRESS
AND THE ADMINISTRATION SO WE WE
ARE PAID A VISIT BY VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE BACK IN OCTOBER.
HE TOURED THE AT THE AIRPORT HE
TOURED VIRGIN AND HE TORTURED
ARCHES WHILE.
I THINK IS A PERSONAL INTEREST
IN THE PERSONAL SPACE INDUSTRY.
WE ARE ALSO IN CONGRESSMAN
KEVIN MCCARTHY IS DISTRICTS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WE DO GET A
LOT OF GREAT ATTENTION.
WITHIN THE SPACE INDUSTRY.
AT ALL JUST ALSO MENTION THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN LIKE IT'S BEEN A
WONDERFUL SUPPORTER OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN MOJAVE AND.
FOR COMPANIES AS WELL.
SO FEDERALLY THERE ARE
CONVERSATIONS TAKING PLACE
REGARDING INTEGRATION INTO THE
NATIONAL AIRSPACE SYSTEM.
BETTER CLASSIFICATION FOR SPACE
PORTS
AND PROMOTING A BETTER
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT.
NATIONWIDE THERE ARE TEN LICENSE
SPACE PORTS WHICH I MENTION
TERMINAL TOUCH ON HERE IN A
LITTLE WHILE.
EACH WITH DIFFERENT
CAPABILITIES AND EACH WITH
VARIOUS STATE SUPPORT.
STATES ARE VERY EAGER TO EARN
THE BUSINESS AND THEY OFFER
INCENTIVES TO OPERATORS.
IT IS BECOMING MORE DIFFICULT
FOR MAHAVIR SPACEPORT TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE AS THE INDUSTRY
CONTINUES TO GROW.
WE NEED INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
AND MORE FAVORABLE LEGISLATION
IN GENERAL.
I DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER SITES BUT
OF THIS.
FOR THAT ONE.
SO AND THE FAA DOES NOT TREAT
LICENSE SPACE PORTS THE WAY THEY
DO AIRPORTS CONGRESS HAS NOT
ALLOCATED A BUDGET.
FOR THE FAA TO OFFER GRANTS TO
SPACE PORTS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS.
SO INDIVIDUAL STATES ARE TAKING
THIS ON DIRECTLY.
IF CALIFORNIA WERE TO OFFER AN
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
THROUGH CALTRANS.
YOU HAVE TWO CUSTOMER HERE
TODAY.
WHO CAN QUICKLY PROVE RETURN ON
THE STATE'S INVESTMENT?
WE HAVE BEEN NEED TODAY TO
SUPPORT OUR CURRENT CUSTOMER
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS RETAIN THE
SPACE START UPS IN CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS WE
HAVE A NEED TO EXPAND TO SUPPORT
OUR CUSTOMER GROWTH.
TO ACCOMPANY PUTTING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INTO VEHICLE PRODUCTION
AND TESTING. RECEIVING ANOFFER
OF A FREE FACILITY IN ANOTHER
STATE IS THAT IS AN OFFER THAT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
REFUSE.
I'M NOT HERE TO ASK THE STATE TO
BUILD HANGARS IN MOJAVE
IT WERE OFFERED.
I WANT THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS TO
UNDERSAND THE CHALLENGES THEY
FACE WHICH ARE SIMPLE
LEGISLATIVE CORRECTIONS THAT
WILL ENABLE ME TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER STATES.
FIRST
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO BORROW
MONEY JUST AS ANY OTHER ENTITY
CAN BORROW MONEY. WITHOUT THE
RESTRICTION OF P. UC TWO TWO
FIVE FIVE SEVEN. WHICH LIMITS MY
BORROWING TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW AIRPORTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENTLY OPERATING IN THE
BLACK.
OUR ABILITY TO BORROW MONEY
SHOULD BE BASED ONLY ON OUR
CREDIT WORTHINESS AND NOT
WHETHER WE ARE AN AIRPORT
DISTRICT.
SECOND BECAUSE WE'RE A PUBLIC
AGENCY WE ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
PREVAILING WAGES FOR ANY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT
CHOOSE THE THIRTY FIVE PERCENT
PREMIUM. OVER MARKET RATE.
WE WOULD BE GRATEFUL FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO OPEN DISCUSSIONS
WITH MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY IN
STAFF ABOUT HOW THE COMMERCIAL
SPACE INDUSTRY MIGHT BENEFIT
FROM REDUCING CONSTRUCTION
COSTS.
LOWERING THE COST
AND ALLOWING ME TO BORROW MONEY
WILL ENABLE ME TO GROW.
I HAVE FIVE EXISTING CUSTOMERS
WHO WOULD LEASE A NEW HANGAR
TODAY IF IT WERE AVAILABLE. NOT
TO MENTION THE NUMEROUS
COMPANIES I HAVE TO TURN AWAY
DUE TO LACK OF SPACE.
THIS PROCESS HAS BECOME QUITE
FRUSTRATING FOR MOJAVE. WELL
OTHER STATES ARE OFFERING BRAND
NEW FACILITIES TO MY CURRENT
CUSTOMERS
FREE.
I CAN YOU TAKE OUT A LOAN TO
HELP THEM EXPAND IN CALIFORNIA.
SEVERAL STATES ARE AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUING MY EXISTING CUSTOMERS.
SINCE I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE MAHABIR
SPACE PORT HAS HOSTED SPACEPORT
TEAMS FROM TEXAS NEW MEXICO
COLORADO HAWAII AND FLORIDA.
THE DOMESTIC INTERESTS HOWEVER
IS ONLY A FRACTION.
OF THE INTEREST WE SEE IN
MOJAVE.
WE HAVE ALSO HOSTED SEVERAL
PROSPECTIVE SPACE PORT TEAMS
FROM THE UK. ITALY FRANCE
AUSTRALIA SWEDEN GERMANY AND
AUSTRIA.
PEOPLE LIKE ME.
WHO BELIEVE THIS INDUSTRY WILL
CHANGE THE WORLD?
WILL FOLLOW THIS INDUSTRY
ANYWHERE IF THAT MEANS I CAN
PROVIDE SOME SMALL AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT TO WATCH IT SUCCEED.
BUT I'M ADVOCATE FOR MOJAVE.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE CALIFORNIA
SUCCEED AT I WANT TO SEE THE
COMMERCIAL SPACE COMPANIES
SUCCEED AND MY HOBBY REALLY IS
AN IDEAL PLACE FOR THEM TO
OPERATE.
MY HOBBY IS WORTHY OF INVESTMENT
BY THE STATE AND I DO A BILL
CONSIDER SUPPORTING SOME KIND OF
AN INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
TO HELP RETAIN AND GROW THE
BUSINESS WE ALREADY HAVE AND
ENABLE US TO FOSTER NEW COMPANY
GROWTH.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME
TO SPEAK ON THE INDUSTRY ARE
CHALLENGES AND I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
BUT WHAT ARE WE UP. TO HERE
FROM ALL THE SPEAKERS AND THEN.
WILL OPEN UP FOR
.
HI GOOD MORNING MORNING I THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARTUCCI
FOR.
.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY UP FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AS WELL ON THAT
PARTICULAR TIME TO HOLD THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
TODAY I'M HERE REPRESENTING
HARRIS CORPORATION AND
SPECIFICALLY THE CALIFORNIA
SPACE PORT.
HARRIS CORPORATION THE LEADING
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATOR SOLVING
CUSTOMERS TOUGHEST MISSION
CRITICAL CHALLENGES PART
PROVIDING SOLUTIONS THAT CONNECT
INFORMED PROTECT.
HARRIS EMPLOYS MORE THAN
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING OVER SEVEN THOUSAND
SCIENTISTS AND ENGINEERS ARE
ANNUAL REVENUES ABOUT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS.
MY TEAM REPORTS THROUGH THE
SPACE AN INTELLIGENT SYSTEMS
SEGMENT OF PARIS.
WHICH PROVIDES THE WORLD'S MOST
ADVANCED SENSORS AND PAYLOADS
GROUND PROCESSING SYSTEMS AND
ADVANCED PRODUCTS IN ANALYTICS
FOR GLOBAL SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS.
SPACE SITUATION WHEREIN
AWARENESS AND EARTH OBSERVATION.
I HARRIS IS HEADQUARTERED IN
FLORIDA. HOWEVER WE HAVE OVER
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
EMPLOYEES AND MANY CUSTOMERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE MANAGE AND OPERATE IN CAL WE
WE MANAGE OPERATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS VITAL TO THE STATE'S
FUTURE GROWTH AND COMMERCIAL
SPACE TRANSPORTATION AND THAT IS
THE CALIFORNIA SPACE PORT. AT
VANDENBERG AIRFORCE BASE.
HARRIS IS CALIFORNIA SPACE PORT
IS A COMMERCIALLY OPERATED SPACE
LAUNCH COMPLEX USING LEASED
PROPERTY ON VANDENBERG AIRFORCE
BASE.
THE SPACEPORT CONSISTS OF A
SATELLITE PROCESSING AND
INTEGRATION FACILITY AND A SMALL
LAUNCH PAD.
A WE WERE THE FIRST FAA LICENSED
PRIVATE COMMERCIAL SPACE LAUNCH
SITE OPERATOR IN THE UNITED
STATES AND WE CURRENTLY HOLD THE
ONLY. FAA COMMERCIAL SPACEPORT
LICENSING CALIFORNIA WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO LAUNCH SATELLITES.
INTO ORBIT.
OUR LOCATIONS ON THE CENTRAL
COAST OF CALIFORNIA UNIQUELY
SITUATED.
AT THE POINT WHERE THE NORTH
SOUTH BEACH'S BEGIN TO TURN EAST
WEST
I THIS DEEMS THE GEOGRAPHY OF
THE SPACEPORT AT VANDERBURGH
IDEAL FOR LAUNCHING INTO POLAR
OR SUN SYNCHRONOUS ORBITS.
A POLAR ORBITER IMPORTANT
BECAUSE AT THE SATELLITE ORBITS
AT A LOW ALTITUDE FROM POLE TO
POLE. THE EARTH ROTATES BLOW IT.
SO OVER THE COURSE OF EACH DAY
THE SATELLITE WILL PASSED OVER
THE ENTIRE PLANET.
THESE ORBITS ARE IDEAL FOR
EARTH MONITORING MISSIONS LIKE
WEATHER SATELLITES LAND
MONITORING EARTH IMAGING.
MAPPING APPLICATIONS
I WE ARE THE ONLY LOCATION IN
THE CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES
THE PERMITS SOUTHERN TRAJECTORY
LAUNCHES.
FROM CALIFORNIA TOWARD TO SOUTH
POLE WITHOUT OVERFLIGHT OF ANY
POPULATED AREAS.
THE HARRIS SPACE PORT FACILITY
COMPLETED CONSTRUCTION IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. AND WAS
OFFICIALLY DEBT OFFICIALLY
DESIGNATED A SPACE LAUNCH
COMPLEX EIGHT KNOWN IN THE
COMMUNITY AS SLICK EIGHT.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO PROVIDE A LOW
COST ALTERNATIVE FOR BOTH
COMMERCIAL AND GOVERNMENT LAUNCH
VEHICLE PROVIDERS INTERESTED IN
USING SMALLER ROCKETS.
TO LAUNCH SMALLER SATELLITES
INTO SPACE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FINANCED USING
PRIVATE INVESTMENT DOLLARS WITH
SOME GRANT FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL AND CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENTS.
AND WAS DESIGNED TO ACCOMMODATE
A LARGE VARIETY OF SMALLER CLASS
LAUNCH VEHICLES.
HOWEVER SINCE ITS INCEPTION THE
SPACEPORT HAS ONLY SUPPORTED
NINE LAUNCHES.
OUR THIS MODEST USED IS MOSTLY
ATTRIBUTED ATTRIBUTABLE TO A
LACK OF DEMAND. AND LACK OF A
BILL AVAILABILITY FOR SMALL
SATELLITE LAUNCH CAPABILITY BUT
DEMAND IS CHANGING RAPIDLY.
NOT SO SIMILAR TO THE AYE
PREVIOUS.
PRESENTER I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE VENTURE CAPITALISTS
SO HERE YOU CAN SEE THAT OVER
THE PAST FEW YEARS THE SPACE
INDUSTRY HAS EXPERIENCED A
RISING DEMAND FOR SMALL
SATELLITES. OF THIS A FROM
REFRIGERATOR SIZED DOWN TO
SHOEBOX SIZED AND SMALLER. A
SMALL SATELLITES ARE SMALL SATS
ARE CHANGING THE COMMERCIAL
SPACE INDUSTRY.
SMALL SATS ALSO REFERRED TO AS
NANO SATIN CUBESATS
CAN BE BUILT ENTIRELY WITH
COMMERCIAL OFF THE SHELF
COMPONENTS AND THEIR DECREASE
DEVELOPMENT COSTS MAKE SPACE
EXPLOITATION ACCESSIBLE TO MUCH
SMALLER COMPANIES AND STUDENTS
AT MOST. COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
TODAY ONE OF THE LARGEST
BARRIERS THAT SMALL SACK COMPANY
SPACE IS THE COST OF ROCKET
LAUNCHERS.
LAUNCH SERVICE CONTRACT PRICES
ARE DROPPING WITH INCREASED
COMPETITION AND SUCCESSFUL
DEMONSTRATIONS OF REUSABLE
LAUNCH VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
SPACEX'S DEMONSTRATED. A HOWEVER
FOR SMALL SAT THE ONLY WAY TO
SPACE TODAY AT THE HITCH A RIDE.
WITH A LARGER SATELLITE LAUNCH
LEAVING THE SMALL SAT AT THE
MERCY OF THE PRIMARY MISSION AND
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO CONTROL
ITS OWN DESTINY. IN TERMS OF
SCHEDULE OR FINAL ORBIT.
DESTINATION.
IN ORDER FOR SMALL SETS TO
DICTATE THEIR SPECIFIC OR BILL
REQUIREMENTS THEY MUST BE ABLE
TO HIRE A DEDICATED LAUNCH
SERVICE.
NOT TO OVERCOME THIS BARRIER
SEVERAL NEW COMPANIES ARE
BEGINNING TO COMPETE FOR THIS
GROWING DEDICATED SMALL SAT
LAUNCH MARKET.
I THIS IS THE NEXT BIG STEP TO
COMMERCIAL ACCESS TO SPACE
DEDICATED SMALL SAT LAUNCHERS.
THE NEW ROCKETS TRYING TO
CAPTURE THIS MARKET ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER THAN THE
MORE TRADITIONAL ROCKETS OF
TODAY AND THE PAST.
HOW TO PROPERLY SERVICE THIS
MARKET COMPANIES MUST INCLUDE
THE CAPABILITY FOR LAUNCHING
INTO POLAR ORBITS
BECAUSE MANY THE SMALL SET
MISSIONS? I INVOLVE EARTH
SENSING PAY VOTES.
SEVERAL THESE NEW ROCKET
COMPANIES ARE CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANIES SUCH AS ROCKET LAB
HEADQUARTERED IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH.
AND MANY HAVE LARGE ENGINEERING
OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING VECTOR IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND ASTRA SPACE IN
ALAMEDA.
INTERESTINGLY THOUGH THESE
COMPANIES THESE CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES BETTER CHASING THIS
EMERGING DEDICATED SMALL SAT
LAUNCH MARKET ARE TAKING THEIR
INITIAL LAUNCH OPERATIONS
OUTSIDE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ROCKET LAB BUILT THEIR OWN
LAUNCH COMPLEX IN NEW ZEALAND.
AND THE OTHERS ARE COMPLETING
THEIR FIRST WATCHES FROM KODIAK
ALASKA. THE ONLY OTHER FAA
LICENSED LOCATION IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT'S AUTHORIZED FOR
POLAR LAUNCH OPERATIONS.
ARE THESE DISTANCE LAUNCH SITES
CREATE SIGNIFICANT LOGISTICS
ISSUES AND DRIVE DEVELOPMENT
COSTS.
SO WE NEED TO ASK OURSELVES WHY
ARE THESE COMPANIES INCLINED TO
LAUNCH OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHAT CAN WE DO TO GROW THIS
INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE.
OUR FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
BELIEVE.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL
SPACEPORT SHOULD BE THE FIRST
CHOICE LAUNCH LOCATION FOR ALL
THESE COMPANIES.
BOB SPACEPORT HAS SOME
DEFICIENCIES IN CHALLENGERS.
A THE INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE
CALIFORNIA SPACE PORT IS
LACKING.
THE NEEDS FOR ROCKETS HAVE
CHANGED OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS AND MOST OF THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NO LONGER
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT THESE NEW
ROCKET CONCEPTS.
THESE COMPANIES NEED
CONCRETE PADS BASIC LIQUID
ROCKET ENGINE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE MODULAR STORAGE
ASSEMBLY BUILDINGS.
AT AS KARINA MENTION THE STATE
OF FLORIDA VIRGINIA ALASKA THEY
PROVIDE MUCH OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE OUT THERE SPACE
PORTS. ARE OR THEY PROVIDE
MATCHING STATE GRANTS FOR
PRIVATE INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT.
SECOND THE REGULATORY HURDLES
FOR LAUNCHING A NEW TYPE OF
ROCKET ON A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RANGE ARE DAUNTING.
EACH COMPANY HAS TO COORDINATE
OVERLAPPING REQUIREMENTS OF TO
FEDERAL AGENCIES THE FAA AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
THE REGULATIONS OF THESE FEDERAL
AGENCIES WERE DESIGNED AROUND
PUBLIC SAFETY SOMETHING HARRIS
TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY.
BUT THESE REGULATIONS WERE
ESTABLISHED WITH MEDIUM TO LARGE
CLASS ROCKETS IN MIND.
HOLDING SMALL SAT LAUNCH
VEHICLES TO THE SAME STANDARDS
AS LARGER ROCKETS IS TIME AND
COST PROHIBITIVE. AND OFTEN
RESULT IN UNNECESSARY EFFORTS TO
PROVE OR DEMONSTRATE THE NON
APPLICABILITY OF THE EXISTING
REGULATIONS.
ADDITIONALLY THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL PERMITTING CAN BE
TIME CONSUMING AND CUMBERSOME
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT IN
THE VITAL LANCE WE LEASE FROM
THE AIRFORCE IS A RESPONSIBILITY
WE YET HARRIS. TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN APPROVED
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT FOR
SPACE PORT THAT RESULTED IN A
FINDING OF NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
OR FONZIE WITH THE EXPECTATION
WE WOULD BE LAUNCHING LARGER.
SOLID ROCKET BASED LAUNCH
VEHICLES.
BUT THE ADDITION OF NEW SMALLER
CLEANER ROCKETS TO OUR
OPERATIONS SHOULD NOT REQUIRE
ANY NEW ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
AND FINALLY.
THE HIGH COST OF OPERATING
CALIFORNIA FROM COSTA LIVING TO
ENERGY COSTS PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO COMMERCIAL SPACE
LAUNCH INDUSTRY.
AS EVERYONE OPERATING AT
VANDERBURGH CAN ATTEST THE AGING
UTILITY SERVICES SPECIAL
ELECTRICITY ARE EXPENSIVE TO
USERS BUT ALSO PROVIDE AN
UNACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF
RELIABILITY. THE NUMBER OF
UNPLANNED POWER OUTAGES ARE
GLITCHES EACH YEAR IS
SIGNIFICANT. DRIVING INDUSTRY TO
LOOK FOR ALTERNATIVE POWER
SOURCES AND ENGINEER REDUNDANT
SYSTEMS
TO PROTECT THEIR GROUND SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT IN FLIGHT HARDWARE.
FROM THE EXISTING EROTIC POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BACK UP GENERATORS BECOME A
NECESSITY IN THE NORM. AND THESE
COME WITH THEIR OWN SET OF
PROBLEMS INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
PERMITTING.
I WE AT HARRIS ARE HONORED TO
OPERATE CALIFORNIA SPACEPORT AND
ARE COMMITTED TO SEEING THIS
COMMERCIAL SPACEPORT FLOURISH
OVER THE NEXT DECADE. WE ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS OR SPACEPORT GRANTS
TO ATTRACT NEW BUSINESS TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
REVIEW EXISTING ENVIRONMENTAL
RICK REGULATIONS FOR
STREAMLINING WHEREVER WHEREVER
FEASIBLE.
AND MAYBE CONSIDERING
ESTABLISHING AN OFFICE WITHIN
CALTRANS TO COORDINATE
COMMERCIAL SPACE TRANSPORTATION
ACTIVITIES
TO CONSOLIDATE AND SYNCHRONIZE
THE COORDINATES COORDINATION
WITH THE COGS IN FEDERAL
AGENCIES.
AND FINALLY AS WE KNOW YOU'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR NEW STEM
EDUCATION INCENTIVES CONSIDER
NEW FUNDING FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL
KEEPS AT DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
POSSIBLY MODELED AFTER THE
PROGRAM INITIATED SEVERAL IRVINE
AREA HIGH SCHOOLS.
I WE SEE THIS EMERGING
COMMERCIAL SMALL SIDE ENTERPRISE
AS A GROWTH MARKET FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TOGETHER WITH THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE STATE IN
ADDITION TO OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
TO ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA
SPACEPORT BECOMES THE GO TO
OPERATIONAL LAUNCH LOCATION. FOR
DEDICATED SMALL SAT LAUNCHES IN
THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU
I VERY MUCH
.
TESTING.
BACK TO TOP THERE HAS TO.
AS A GET TOGETHER PUBLIC.
I GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SHERMAN COUNCIL AND.
I'M WITH THE OFFICE OF A
COMMERCIAL SPACE TRANSPORTATION.
STAY LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE INTRODUCTION A. S. T..
FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TODAY AND SHARING
WHAT WE DO IN A CITY.
THIS MIGHT BE THE SECOND TIME
YOU SEEN HIS PRESENTATION SO
OUT.
OF WORKING THAT IN MIND.
SECOND I THINK IT'S FITTING
THAT.
PRESENT AT THE END BECAUSE OF
THE MAJORITY OF THE COMPANIES WE
TALKED ABOUT ARRAY TODAY.
HAS APPLY FOR SOME
AUTHORIZATION TO OUR OFFICE.
IT IN PARTICULAR EVA TALKED
ABOUT SPACEX.
WILL TALKED ABOUT VIRGIN
CREATES TOUGH ABOUT MY HOBBY AND
DAN TOOK A COUPLE SPACE PORT.
SOLVE DIFFERENT CITIES HAVE COME
TO OUR OFFICE FOR THE VARIOUS.
AUTHORIZATIONS.
OKAY SO OUR STATUTORY AUTHORITY
RESIDES ON THE DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION. OUR IS
AUTHORIZES THE FAA TO LICENSE
COMMERCIAL LAUNCH AND ENTRY
ACTIVITIES.
THAT THE OPERATION OF LAUNCH
AND REENTRY SITES.
FAA SERVER TO TO.
EXERCISE IF POSSIBILITY.
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY.
A SAFE YOUR PROPERTY NATIONAL
SECURITY. FOREIGN POLICY
INTERESTS OF UNITED STATES.
WE ALSO HAVE A UNIQUE.
DIRECTION TO ENCOURAGE
FACILITATE PROMOTE.
DOT TYPICALLY MEANS IN OUR PRE
AT PROCESS SEES WE OFTEN TIMES.
ASSIST THE APPLICANT WITH
VARIOUS THINGS THAT THAT MAY
BECOME ISSUE TO THE PROM BY
SITTING PROCESS.
AND THE LAST BULLET IS REALLY
STATE THAT.
.
WE.
DO NOT AUTHORIZE.
LAUNCH THAT ARE FORMED BY THAT
THE GOVERNMENT.
ESSENTIALLY.
OKAY AS FAR AS A LICENSING
PROCESS.
THIS IS A QUICK BREAKDOWN OF OF
WHAT IT IS.
I A ENTITY MUST OBTAIN A LICENSE
TO LAUNCH.
LAUNCH VEHICLE FROM THE U. S..
TO OPERATE IN THE ON SITE WITH
IN THE U. S. AND TO RE ENTER A
VEHICLE.
AND UNITED STATES
AND TO OPERATE A RE ENTRY SITE.
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES.
ALSO YOU US CITIZENS OR ENTITY
ORGANIZED UNDER THE LAWS OF THE
UNITED STATES OR ANY STATE MUST
OBTAIN A LICENSE.
.
TO LAUNCH A LAUNCH VEHICLE
OUTSIDE THE U. S.. TO OPERATED
LAUNCH SITE OUTSIDE THE US AND
TO RE ENTER A REENTRY VEHICLE
OUTSIDE THE U. S..
AND TOO ARE PRETTY NOT PAY
REENTRY SITE. OUTSIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IN EXTRA.
THE IN TWO THOUSAND ONE I CAME
ON BOARD TO A IS T. WE ONLY HAD
THIRTY FIVE STAFF MEMBERS TOTAL.
RIGHT NOW IS ABOUT A THIRD OF
WHAT WE HAVE NOW.
TODAY WE HAVE NINETY EIGHT FULL
TIME FEDERAL EMPLOYEES IN THE
SEA.
MOSTLY IN DC WE HAVE FIELD
OFFICES IN FLORIDA TEXAS AND OF
COURSE CALIFORNIA'S WHEN I'M
BASED. A BEEN HERE ABOUT FIVE
YEARS NOW.
AND THE REASON WHY WE SENT
PEOPLE FROM DC TO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THE THE LINGERIE AND
ACTIVITIES PICKING UP ARE QUITE
QUITE FAST.
STORES ARE BUDGET IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR A
WE HAVE NINETEEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
ON THE BOOKS.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN RESEARCH
THE BUDGET WE HAVE TWO AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
OUR OWN THE BOOKS FOR.
THE BUDGET FOR TWO OF NINETEEN.
GUESS A COMPARISON TO THE REST
OF THE FAA WE ARE A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF BUSINESS BUT WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK IN TERMS OF
THE SPACE OPERATIONS THAT ARE
CONCURRENT OCCURRING O. POLLUTED
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
AS FOLLOWS A LIKE SEEING HOW
BREAKS DOWN THERE ARE THREE
MAJOR PHASES IN LICENSING
PROCESS WHICH INCLUDES.
THE FREE APPLICATION
CONSULTATION.
LICENSING EVALUATION.
APPLICATION ACCEPTANCE AND THEN
LAUNCH OPERATIONS.
THE VERY TOP ERA THERE IS TO
THREE ITEMS SPEAKING.
AND.
.
SO I WAS GONNA GO TO THE
QUESTION THAT CAME UP EARLIER
FROM.
THE MEMBER I THINK SHARON AND
ASKED ABOUT THE PROCESS FOR WHAT
HOW WE INCORPORATE LAUNCHES INTO
NAZ.
THEY ARE DOZEN AGREEMENT THAT'S
REQUIRED BY THE APPLICANT TO.
.
COULD GET HAVE FOR.
THE IMPACT TO THE LAST WHICH IS
A LOW A LOT OF AGREEMENT. AND A
TF ARE IT'S TYPICALLY ISSUE. TO
SENATE SANTOS AEROSPACE TO AVOID
ANY IMPACT TO THE AIRCRAFT IN
DESTIN AREA.
SO I THINK THAT IS THE THE
PROCESS THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S A. PRETTY A
RELIABLE SOURCE OF OF
INFORMATION THAT THE LOCAL AIR
TRAFFIC CENTER HAS IN HIS
POSSESSION. DONE THE VARIOUS
OPERATIONS THAT THEY CAN USE IT
SENT OUT THEIR SPACE NOW
QUESTIONS A VERY VALID ONE WE
ARE CURRENTLY WORKING WITH A T.
O. ATTRACT ORGANIZATION TO
ADDRESS THOSE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS.
I'M NOT A PROBLEM WE WE
ANTICIPATE. THAT THE LOTTERY TO
PICK UP.
I THINK THE TIMING OF IT IS
KIND UNCERTAIN BUT YOU CAN SEE
IT COMING.
I THINK THAT.
IS IS OUR IS DUE DILIGENCE TO
START TALKING ABOUT THESE THINGS
MORE AND SEWER INTERACTING WITH
A TEAL.
AS OFTEN AS WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY MAJOR ISSUES.
WITHIN PACK AND AIR SPACE DOES
AS IT EXISTS TODAY.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE TALK
ABOUT TWO IS THE POLICY REVIEW
PALER REVIEW.
FINANCIAL FLEXIBILITY ALL
PIECES OF THE VALUATION. SO THE
COMPANIES THAT CAME UP EARLIER
HAS ALL ALL HAVE GONE THROUGH
THIS PROCESS FOR OBTAINING A
LICENSE FOR LUNCH SAY. THE
PAYING A LICENSE FOR A LAUNCH
VEHICLE.
AND IN THE VERY RIGHT SOUTH OF
THAT DIET LINE THERE WE HAVE
WHAT WE CALL COMPLIANCE
MONITORING SAGE.
WHERE?
ARE.
SAFETY INSPECTORS ACTUALLY SIT
ON CONSOLE FOR ALL OF THE
VARIOUS MISSIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THE CAPACITY A
LICENSE AND. AND REPUTATION MADE
AN APPLICATION.
SO THIS IS A A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT THE CREDITOR PATH TO LOOK
LIKE IN THE FUTURE.
AND CURRENTLY HAS A SENSE TODAY
SO. RIGHT NOW WE ARE ACTUALLY
INVOLVED AND CONCERNED WITH JUST
A PUBLIC SAFETY EXPECT OF THESE
LAUNCHES.
FROM VARIOUS PLACES ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY AND WORLD.
I THE SECOND PHASE THAT WE ARE
ANTICIPATING HIS OCCUPANT
SAFETY.
WHICH WOULD ALSO INCLUDE A
PUBLIC SAFETY OF THE ONCE SEE
MORE TALK MORATORIUM EXPIRES.
IF YOU STANDS ARE DEVELOPED WE
ANTICIPATE THAT HAPPENING.
IN IN THE NEAR TERM.
ONE THING I DID ONE IMAGE INTO
IN THE FIRST PHASE IS THAT WE DO
HAVE A PART FOR SIXTY HUMAN
SPACE FLIGHT REGULATE
REGULATION.
THAT'S IN EFFECT AND ARE OFFERS
UP THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SPACE
FLIGHT PARTICIPANTS ON THEIR
INFORMED CONSENT REGIME. TO UP
PARTICIPATING THESE VARIOUS.
SPACE OPERATIONS OF FROM THE
VARIOUS COMPANIES.
AND UP TO THE FAR RIGHT.
THERE IS.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER BOX THEIR
MISSION ASSURANCE.
WE THINK AT SOME POINT AND I'M
THINKING MAYBE A DECADE OR SO
FROM NOW.
WOODSTOCK CERTIFYING THESE UP
PERSON SOMEONE WHO WHAT THE
AVIATION IS IS DOING NOW FOR.
THE AVIATION WORLD. OF INDEX
SAID TIMING IS THAT IT'S NOT
SURE. BUT THAT'S KIND OF
DIRECTION WE'RE GOING AND TO
PREPARE FOR THAT.
AS WE GO TO A LICENSING PROCESS
WE'RE LOOKING MORE INTO. A
VEHICLE DEVELOPMENT.
REASONABLE REUSABILITY OF
DIFFERENT VEHICLES.
THE MAINTENANCE THAT THE
COMPANIES ARE CONSIDERING FOR.
THE REPEATING FLIGHT SIM REP
REPETITIVE FLIGHTS.
SO THOSE ARE SOME THINGS THAT
WILL FOCUS ON.
FOR FOR THE FUTURE TESTS OF
FLIGHT REGIME.
AS IT MIGHT LOOK SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE AVIATION WORLD IS
CURRENTLY DONE.
SO WHICH IS IT'S EXPECTED SPACE
PORTS THIS IS A QUICK SNAPSHOT
THINK COMMUNITY OUT BUT THIS
EARLIER WE HAVE.
TEN LICENSE SPACEPORT. ON
SEVERAL IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
LICENSING PROCESS IN PRE OP AND
UNDER EVALUATION ABOUT HALF OF
THOSE.
WE'VE LICENSE HAVE REGULAR
LAUNCH ACTIVITIES.
FORTUNATELY I THINK I CAN SAY
THIS PRINT PROBABLY THAT TWO OF
THE MORE ACTIVE ONES ARE. IN
CALIFORNIA.
DANCE AREA AND ALSO IN MY HOBBY
SO THAT IS VERY VERY.
PROMISING FOR THE ACTIVIST IS
HAPPENING OUT IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMMERCIAL SPACE IN
CALIFORNIA WE WE ARE ONCE
ECONOMY. DISCUSS.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO TO LICENSE
FACE POOR AS I JUST MENTIONED.
.
TEN PLUS EVERY OTHER BROWN'S
VEHICLE OPERATIONS.
ONE FAA IS TCO E. MEMBER
UNIVERSITY.
THROUGH OVER LAUNCH OPERATIONS.
A NUMBER OF CELL LATE COMPANY
SUPPLIERS AND OTHER RELIANCE ON
THE LAUNCH INDUSTRY.
INNOVATORS.
IN SELLING SERVICING ASTEROIDS
THE MOON MINING COMMERCIAL SPACE
STATIONS AND MORE. ARE ALL HOME
TO CALIFORNIA SPACE.
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE SOME NEW OVER THE
LAUNCH TO. THEIR RESPECTIVE
HAPPEN.
INTO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. OF SUMMER THE
HYBRID TIGHT LIKE THE V. G.
CRITICAL ACTIVE VERSION ORBIT.
AND AND OTHER COMPANIES LIKE SO
MUCH AS WELL MAY BE IN THAT SAME
CATEGORY.
MAJOR SOURCES OF VENTURE
CAPITAL LIKE I WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER IT IS A IT'S A FOCAL
POINT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE WE LOOK FORWARD TO A
ASSISTING YOU IN ANY OF THESE
ERRORS AT THE AS WE CAN FAA.
THE MAP ON THE RIGHT TO SHOWS A
BREAKDOWN OF THE DIFFERENT AREAS
OF BAY AREA IN SACRAMENTO. A LOS
ANGELES IN THE VARIOUS COMPANIES
THAT ARE OPERATING OUT THERE
THAT ARE ON THE COMMERCIAL
SPACE.
SAID DECAYING AND.
.
MOJAVE UP LIKE WE SAID EARLIER
IS A DUFFY A FOCAL POINT IN
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF ACTIVITY
HERE IN THE NEAR TERM.
THINK OF WILL MENTION THAT
VERSION ELECTED JUST COMPLETED
OUR A POWER FLIGHT AND THERE'S
MORE TO COME HERE.
IN THIS MONTH THE BEGINNING OF
NEXT MONTH.
SO FOR THE.
.
HERE.
OF FOR SPACE PORTS HAVE BEEN
ISSUED.
FOR THE STATE GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY'VE SEEN
SOME IN ECONOMIC DRIVERS IN HIGH
TECH JOB CLUBS.
WE LICENSE SPACE PUTS ON THE
PART FOR TWENTY. ESSENTIALLY.
WOULD LOOK AT IN ROMAN IMPACT
TYPE OF OPERATIONS VEHICLE
ENVISIONS.
AIRSPACE ACCESS ARE REVIEWED
SOME OF LISTING OUT IF YOU WERE
TO APPLY FOR A LAUNCH SITE
LYSONS.
YOU WE WILL LOOK AT THE VARIOUS.
COMPONENTS THAT WOULD HAVE US.
YOU UNDERSTAND BETTER HOW THE
OPERATION WOULD TAKE PLACE. IN A
TYPE OF VEHICLES AS COULD BE
ACCEPTING FROM THOSE LOCATIONS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE THREE
CATEGORIES OF VERTICAL LAUNCH.
HORIZONTAL LAUNCH AND HIGH
ALTITUDE BALLOON LAUNCH CAN ALSO
BE. ON THE OUR AUTHORITY
DEPENDING ON THE.
FIT JUST GREATER THAN THAT OF
CRITERIA THAT THAT WE OFTENTIMES
LOOK AT TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
OF THE ACROPORA IS MUST APPLY
FOR A SEPARATE LUNCH LICENSE OR
PERMIT TO OPERATE FROM A
SPECIFIC SPACE PORT. OF ENTRY IS
INCREASINGLY USING FULLY
COMMERCIAL SITE WHERE THEY MUST
PROVIDE MORE OF THEIR OWN
SERVICES.
FOR INSTANCE GROUND SAFETY.
IN ADDITION TO THE EXISTING
FEDERAL FACILITY.
I'LL FAA.
HAS
SET UP SPACE CATEGORIZATION
AVIATION RULE MAKING COMMITTEES.
THAT IS CURRENTLY IN WORK NOW
ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE A BEEN
BROUGHT FOR BY THE INDUSTRY WE
TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS ON RULE MAKING HERE
NEAR TERM THAT WILL HOPEFULLY IN
THE TEN IS TO.
MITIGATE SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
OR ISSUES THAT THAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED.
HERE IN THE LAST MONTH OR SO.
A MAYES PUT MOST BASS PORTS HAVE
OFFICIAL STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACTING A SOME DON'T AS WAS MISS
MENTIONED EARLIER.
FAA IS AUTHORIZED TO ISSUE
SPACE TRANSPORTATION MATCHING
GRANTS.
WHEN APPROPRIATE WOULD PROFIT
FUNDS AVAILABLE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE THE GRANT PROGRAM. IS
THIS IN A KIND OF A BIT OF A
HIATUS.
.
IT WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR BUT IN AN ACTIVE
SINCE.
FY TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
I GUESS THE MAIN POINT I WANT TO
MAKE HERE IS THAT.
THE STEM IS STILL AUTHORIZED
HAS BEEN FUNDED HAS NOT BEEN FUN
FOR A FEW YEARS.
BUT THIS COULD BE A CHANGE IF
WE GET ENOUGH BUDGET.
THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION IF IF CREATED. COMPLY
FOR STEM GRANTS AND THE HAVE ON
BEHALF OF TELEPHONE SPACEPORT.
THIS DIM GRANT PROGRAM BECOMES
ACTIVE AGAIN SO THIS IS A AYE
AVENUE THAT THE COMMITTEE CAN
CONSIDER.
FOR THE GRANTS AND THAT MIGHT
BE NEEDED FOR VARIOUS.
OPERATIONS ON THE COMMERCIAL
SPACE UMBRELLA.
THIS IS A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF OF.
DIFFERENT VARIOUS.
LAUNCHES THIS HAPPEN OVER THE
YEARS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TO
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THERE'S
BEEN TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE LICENSE ON CHIP THEN THE
PERIOD. OF FORTY FIVE PERMIT
LAUNCHES.
THE THERE'S BEEN INCREASED IN
RECENT YEARS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
PARTICULARLY.
BECAUSE OF THE SATELLITE
SERVICES HAS BEEN PROVIDED.
YOU CAN SEE.
THE TRAIN OF DIPPING IN AND
KIND OF COMING UP.
WOULD PUT THE NUMBER OF FLIGHTS
SO THE NAME OF YEARS.
THAT'S TYPICALLY DO TO.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE SOME COUNTY
EVENT IN A AND A OPERATION. THAT
WE CANNOT AFFECT THE ENTIRE
INDUSTRY.
IF AS A COMMON COMPONENT OR
COMMON INJURY OF COMMON.
TYPE OF FLIGHT.
A KIND OF. TRICKLES DOWN IN
EFFECT INTO INDUSTRY BUT LATELY
THAT THE TRAIN HAS BEEN GOING UP
QUITE A BIT AND WE HAVEN'T SEEN.
THAT TYPE OF.
ISSUE THAT WOULD IMPACT THE
INCREASE IN INDUSTRY THAT MUCH
IN AND THE.
ELEVEN LATER YEARS.
SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
INJURIES IS EXPANDING ITS
COMMERCIAL CAPABILITIES.
WITH A VARIETY OF LAUNCH
OPERATIONS TIM FROM BG.
HYBRID WING LAUNCH SYSTEM TO
BLUE ORIGINS AND SPACEX'S.
OF VERTICAL TAKEOFF AND WHOSE
ABILITY FOR FIRST DAYS LANDINGS
AND THEN ALSO THAT.
THE BIGELOW ARIS BIGELOW
AEROSPACE WHO MANUFACTURES AND
DEVELOPS.
EXPANDABLE SPACE STATIONS OF
MODULES.
I THINK THE CHARTER IS A IS A
GOOD INDICATOR FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IN INDUSTRY. AND
SOME OF THE THE EXCITING.
COMMERCIAL SPACE ADVENTURE
OPERATES NAKED THAT'S.
PROBABLY DOWN. A LITTLE BIT BUT
SURELY SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER HAPPENING.
AND A NEAR TERM.
SO INVESTMENTS IN NEW MARKETS IN
AND VEHICLES.
.
I JUST LIKE TO SUMMARIZE BUSTING
THE COMMERCIAL SPACE HAS BEEN.
SEEN RECORD INVESTMENT OVER LAST
COUPLE YEARS.
AND SPECIFICALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN A STUDY FOUND PRIVATE
INVESTMENTS IN COMMERCIAL SPACE.
OVERALL HAS INCREASED.
AND MANY OF THE COMPANIES
RECEIVING FUNDING ARE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA.
GOT INCLUDING THE VENTURE
VENTURE CAPITAL FIRMS THEY'RE
GETTING HEAVILY AYE INVOLVED
LATELY.
A COMMERCIAL MONEY A GIVEN
REVENUE FROM A GLOBAL SPACE
ACTIVITY WAS ABOUT.
TOWARD TO SIXTY BILLION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
THE TALK SHOWS THAT MOST OF THE
MONEY COMES FROM.
SATELLITE SERVICE OF GROUND
EQUIPMENT.
WHICH WOULD INDICATE THAT
LAUNCHES IS ONLY A FRACTION OF
THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY BILLION
DOLLARS FOR. COMMERCIAL MONEY.
IN THIS SHOWS HOW IMPORTANT
LAUNCH AN AIDS TEES MISSION.
IS RELATED AND INFLUENCES THE
INDUSTRY.
SUCCESS AND AND.
.
NO SWORDS AT THE MONEY HOUSE
GOING TO BE.
ADMIT INTO THE THE WHOLE
PROCESS.
FAA AND NATIONAL GOES SO THAT
THE POINT I WANT TO MAKE HERE IS
THAT WE ARE DEFINITELY.
STALKING WITH VARIOUS COMPANIES
AND.
FROM OVERSEAS.
AND WILL WORK WITH OTHER
COUNTRIES INTERESTED HOSTING US
LAUNCH OPERATIONS OR DEVELOPING
THEIR OWN.
ALSO OTHER OBJECTIVES IS TO
SUPPORT US COMPANIES.
THAT.
THINK THEY HAVE A BUSINESS CASE
OVERSEAS ARE THAT WE CAN HELP
WITH.
THIS CHART SHOWS AND EXPAND THE
FOOTPRINT OF WORLDWIDE INCLUDING
THE EXISTING PROPOSED GLOBAL
SPACE PORT.
NEW ZEALAND.
BELOW US BELOW OSTROWY THERE AS
A NEW LAUNCH COMPANY AT THINK
WAS MUCH EARLIER.
BUT BASS OTHER CALIFORNIA.
WITH ROCKET LAB.
OF THEY'VE DONE A LOT OF.
.
DIFFERENT THINGS LATELY AND
ACTUALLY WORKING A. S..
FOR THEIR UPCOMING MISSION AND
IS DOING.
AND IN THE COMING MONTHS.
WE ALSO WORKING WITH UNITED
EVERY. ARAB EMIRATES EMMERICH'S
UK ITALY AND BRAZIL.
AND LOOKING AT COMMERCIAL
LAUNCH SITES IN THE VARIOUS.
LOCATIONS IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
SO THE CENTER OF EXCELLENCE FOR
A IS T..
IS ANOTHER AREA OF
COLLABORATION
BETWEEN A. S. T. AND THE
CALIFORNIA SPACE INDUSTRY.
RIGHT NOW STAMP IS IS A MEMBER.
NASA AMES IS AN ASSOCIATE
MEMBER USC IS WORKING ON
BECOMING AN AFFILIATE MEMBER I
AM BERKELEY HAS SHOWN A LOT A
LOT OF INTEREST RECENTLY.
WITH THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM.
YOU CAN SEE THE TOP FOUR ITEM
ZERO THE FOCAL POINTS AEROSPACE
TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT SPACE POOR
OPERATIONS.
SPACE TRANSPORTATION VEHICLES
IN SPACE FLIGHT AND INITIATE
VIABILITY. AND THAT THAT REALLY
SPEAKS TO THAT THE VARIOUS.
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE THERE
FOR A MEMBER OF THEY WERE TO
BECOME INVOLVED A HALF INTEREST
IN.
AND WHAT WE'RE PRESENTING HERE.
UNDER THE CO E. PROGRAM.
SO LOOKING AHEAD I THINK THE TO
TAKE AWAY IS THAT.
.
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS WAS
DISCUSSING WAYS IS T. AND THE
COP FOUR YEAR.
AEROSPACE COMMITTEE COMMISSION
COULD INTERACT IN SUPPORT OF
OTHER EACH OTHER'S EFFORT.
OUR WILL TO REFORM EFFORTS.
FOR THE ARTICLE ON THE WAY AND
TALKED ABOUT THIS A MINUTE AGO.
AIRSPACE ACCESS SPACE PORTS
INNER.
GRETA REFORMS ARE THE THREE ARCS
THAT ARE.
HAD BEEN PICKED UP THE PACE
HAVE GREAT INTERACTION WITH
INDUSTRY I THINK IT SERVED ITS
PURPOSE. THE GOAL NOW IS TO GET
THE RULE MAKING NOW. THAT.
REALLY ADDRESSES SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE. DISCUSSED
BETWEEN A. S. T. AN ENTRY
REGARDING OF LAUNCHING
CAPABILITY STREAMLINING.
AND CAN MAKE IN THE THE.
REGULATIONS MORE MORE EFFICIENT.
SUPPORT TODAY'S INDUSTRY.
OF POTENTIAL FIAC INTERACTION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE
COMMISSION. OF SO WE HAVE
IN THAT THE TO SUPPOSE THERE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT. ONE OF THE WITH
THE COMMISSION
IN TERMS OF.
.
HOW THE LICENSING STEM GRANT
SIMILAR TO ACTIVITIES WITH OTHER
STE STATE LEVEL SPACE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES? OF THE
FIRST QUESTION IS.
WILL COMMISSION WORK WITH
AIRFORCE WHEN NASA TO EXPAND
COMMERCIAL USE.
OF VANDENBERG ON STONE SIMILAR
TO WHAT SPACE FLORIDA DOES IN
IN.
ON THE EAST COAST WITH NASA AND
KSC.
THAT'S THE QUESTION THE LOVE THE
COMMISSION SUPPORT
FROM A HOBBY. OF THE SPACEPORT
KIND OF ONE UNDERSTAND.
YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AND
HOW WE MIGHT BE OF HELP YOU WITH
THOSE ENDEAVORS.
AND THEN FURTHER COLLABORATION
ON THE ROAD TO REFORM ENTRY
PROMOTES A EFFORTS.
OUR RESEARCH COLLABORATION WITH
UNIVERSITY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMISSION.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE
PREOCCUPATION CONSULTATION AND
LICENSING FOR THE VARIOUS
VEHICLE OPERATIONS.
OTHER INC
OTHER COMPANIES LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA.
.
SO THAT IS THE THE END OF THE
PRESENTATION.
TRYING TO.
CAN GET TO WITH THE INTEREST OF
TIME.
BUT THANK YOU AGAIN FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING TODAY
PUBLIC FOURTEEN QUESTIONS.
RIGHT.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS A.
IT'S REALLY.
A GREAT INFORMATION AND AND.
.
HAVING A PRESENTED FROM ALL
THREE OF YOU TOGETHER AND IT
HELPS ME UNDERSTAND.
.
CALVET ALL COMES TOGETHER.
SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK A.
MS TREES.
THE FIRST.
.
YOU.
GIVE US SOME.
VERY SPECIFIC IDEAS ON.
HOW THIS THE STATE CAN NO BETTER
SUPPORT THE MOJAVE SPACEPORT AS
WELL AS OTHER POTENTIAL SPACE
PORTS AS?
THE COUNCIL.
SUGGESTED.
.
SO THE.
YOU I I BELIEVE YOU INDICATED
THAT.
THAT YOU. RECEIVE NO FAA FUNDS
WITH ITS AT THAT THE STEM
GRANTS.
CRACKED SO  AS A GENERAL
AVIATION AIRPORT WERE ENTITLED
TO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS PER YEAR AND WE
DON'T GET ANY KIND OF A GRANT.
PROGRAM.
FOR BEING A SPACE PORT.THE STIM
GRANTS THAT'S CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED.
DATE DRIED UP I THINK IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE. THOSE WERE A
FIFTH IT WAS A FIFTY FIFTY
PROGRAM AND I THINK IT MAXED OUT
OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IF I'M OF THE
THE TYPES OF GRANTS THAT WE NEED
A FOR INFRASTRUCTURE PERMITS ARE
IN THE MILLIONS.
SO THE THE PROGRAMS THAT EXIST
TODAY THAT WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
DON'T MEET THOSE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY FACING.
.
YOU INDICATED THAT YOU ARE
ROBERT WELL REPRESENTED BY.
A CONGRESSMAN AND.
.
MCCARTHY.
HAS HE.
DELIVERED ANY FEDERAL FUNDS FOR.
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE
SO I AM I US FROM DEALING WITH
THE CHALLENGE CURRENTLY AND.
I WASN'T SURE WHETHER I WOULD
MAKE ANY PROGRESS WITHIN THE FAA
SO MY FIRST CALL WAS TO HIS
OFFICE. OF EXPLAINING THE
CHALLENGE AND SAYING I NEED I
NEED HELP GETTING SOME KIND OF
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY.
AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
AVENUES FOR US RIGHT NOW.
IN TERMS OF THE.
.
ABILITY TO BORROW MONEY ARE YOU
ARE YOU.
.
YEAH ARE YOU SUGGESTING LIKE
BOND FUNDS FROM THE STATE.
AS ODESSA SOURCE OF AN.
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSISTANCE.
WHAT WOULD BE EASIEST FOR US IS
TO JUST HAVE THE ABILITY TO TAKE
OUT ARE A REGULAR BANK CLONE
JUST SAYS MOST ENTITIES CARE ON?
BECAUSE OF THE REGION OR IN ITS
IT'S VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
RAISE BOND MONEY AND WE HAVE
VERY SMALL DISTRICT AND NOT A
LOT OF A PROPERTY OWNERS.
ARE PRESENT IN THAT DISTRICT SO
MOST THINGS MOST THINGS GET
VOTED DOWN TO THE EXTENT THAT
ARE STREET LIGHTS WERE RIPPED
OUT BECAUSE THEY WERE VOTED DOWN
HAVE EVERY TRIED.
WELL WE HAVE NOT TRIED RAISING
BONDS FOR THE AIRPORT.
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T THINK IT
WOULD BE A FRUITFUL EFFORT.
AND VERY LABOR INTENSIVE.
THE OTHER AVENUE THAT WE WERE
SUGGESTED TO PURSUE WAS THROUGH
AYE BANK AND.
AFTER SEVERAL MONTHS
OF PURSUING AYE BANK.
AYE IT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT I HAD ON THE TABLE AT THAT.
AT THE MOMENT.
WAS PURSUING THE I THINK FUNDS
AND BY THE TIME I GOT THE
INVITATION TO APPLY FOR THE I
HATE FUNDS. THAT OPPORTUNITY
DRIED UP. SO I ADDED ESSENTIALLY
START OVER.
SO THAT THAT PROCESS WAS WAS
ALSO QUITE FRUSTRATING WE THIRDS
ASSEMBLYMAN OF LACKEY AT ONE
POINT INTRODUCED SOME
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD HELP US
WITH THE GETTING A NEGOTIABLE
NOTE.
A AND.
THE ASSEMBLY DIDN'T DIDN'T SEEM
TO PUSH BACK BUT THE SENATE DID.
SO IT GOT HELD UP AND SENATE
FINANCE COMMITTEE. AND THEY CAME
BACK TO US BASICALLY SAYING WE
HAD WE HAD NOT PURSUE ALL
AVENUES.
WE COULD GO THROUGH AN
INVESTMENT BANKER WE COULD DO
ALL THESE OTHER OPTIONS BUT THE
REALITY IS. EVERY OTHER OPTION
IS VERY EXPENSIVE FOR US AS A
PUBLIC ENTITY. AND WHERE IT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
ORGANIZATION.
ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
TRADITIONAL BANK LOAN WITH A
WITH A NORMAL INTEREST RATE IS
JUST TOO EXPENSIVE AN OPTION FOR
US.
SO ANYTHING THAT WE WOULD BUILD
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE PASS
THROUGH THOSE COST TO OUR
CUSTOMERS.
AND AND THOSE COSTS ARE TO
BECOME VERY COST PROHIBITIVE
VERY QUICKLY.
SO YOU WOULD BE LESS THAN OF
ACTION TO BE ABLE TO.
TO GET A A.
STANDARD COMMERCIAL BANK LOANS
YES.
THE THEIR PC TWO TWO FIVE FIVE
SEVEN LIMITS ITS ITS SPECIFIC
AIRPORT DISTRICTS AND LIMITS
BORROWING TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR NO GOOD FOR
NEGOTIABLE NOTES SETS THE
STANDARD BANK LOAN.
.
I'M NOT SURE FOR.
I A NO WE STILL HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
VERSION AND.
SPACEX.
.
BUT THEM.
TELL I ASK YOU FIRST.
.
WHAT IS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN?
THE.
.
WHERE THESE COMPANIES ARE
LAUNCHING AND WHERE THEY WOULD
MANUFACTURE?
THERE.
ROCKETS
SO THE MORE MANUFACTURING IN
MOJAVE SO TAKE VIRGIN ORDER FOR
EXAMPLE VIRGIN ORBIT.
THEY'RE DOING THEIR ROCKY
MANUFACTURING IN LONG BEACH.
THEY'RE DOING ALL THEIR ROCKET
TESTING IN MOJAVE AND THEY
INTEND TO DO LAUNCHES FROM
HARVEY AS WELL.
BECAUSE IT'S SO THEIR SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN IS NOT HOUSED IN
MOJAVE BUT WHEN THEY GET READY
TO DO WILL LAUNCH THEIR THIS I'M
FORTY SEVENTY MOHAVE.
THEY BRING THE ROCKETS TO
MOJAVE.
ANYTHING THEY MAY HAVE ON SITE
IS JUST AN EASY WAY TO
TRANSPORT.
AND THEN THEY WOULD CONDUCT
THEIR LUNCHES FROM THERE.
THEY'RE INTERESTED POTENTIALLY
AN EXPANDING OF FOOTPRINT IN
MOJAVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE SEVERAL
EMPLOYEES SAID ARE DRIVING UP
FROM LONG BEACH REGULARLY. SO
THEY'VE GOT TEMPORARY STRUCTURES
SET OUT FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES AND
THEY'D LIKE TO HAVE A AND ACTUAL
FACILITY FOR THEM.
.
AND A MINIMUM A CONCRETE PAD IS
DEDICATED FOR THEIR USE SO.
PRIOR TO THAT THERE ARE STILL
JUST BE USING OUR EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO THEIR LUNCH
PROP.
I ADMIT I WOULD OPEN UP TO TO
ANY OF THE PANELISTS BETTER.
MAIN.
THIS SEEMS TO LOGISTICALLY MAKE
SENSE THAT THERE.
YOU'D WANT TO MANUFACTURE. NEAR
WHERE YOU'RE LAUNCHING.
YES.
SO I AM I A DENTAL DEFTLY
TOUCHED ON THIS I'M SURE AS WELL
BUT.
ARE ARE ISSUE REALLY IS WELL
COUPLE THINGS. THE REMOTE
LOCATION WE HAVE IS FAVORABLE TO
LAUNCH OPERATIONS BUT NOT SO
MUCH WHEN IT COMES TO RECRUITING
TALENT.
SO AND THE REASON THAT COMPANIES
LIKE VIRGIN ORDERFOR INSTANCE
ARE LOCATED ALONG THE JUST
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S WHERE THEY
CAN RECRUIT THE ENGINEERS.
OUTSIDE THAT ARE WILLING TO DO
THOSE JOBS ARE HAPPY TO DO THOSE
JOBS IT'S A LOT HARDER TO
RECRUIT THAT TALENT TO THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY. SO THAT'S
THAT'S JUST REALITIES ARE
LOCATION.
YEAH I'D SAY.
.
SEE CERTAINLY TOUCHED ON.
LOGISTICS ISSUES THAT THAT I
THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT AYE
AYE MY POINT OUT A FEW EXAMPLES
OF SOME COMPANIES THAT ARE
MANUFACTURING. IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THEY'RE TAKING THEIR LAUNCH
ELSEWHERE.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
FIRST OR SECOND TYPE LAUNCHES.
SO IT'S ALL BASED ON VENTURE
CAPITALIST THEY'RE TRYING IT
JUST PROVED THEIR SYSTEM. AYE
ANYWHERE WHERE THEY CAN SAVE
MONEY THEY'RE LOOKING TO SAVE.
AND.
AND SO RIGHT NOW THEY. IF THEY
BEEN FACED WITH A WORKMAN THE
LAST YEAR TO WITH THIS DECISION.
WE WANNA PAY ACTUALLY JUST SIX
AND TAKE IT TO KODIAK WHERE
KODIAK HAS SOME MORE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE THE STATE
WILL WORK WITH US AND WHERE WE
ONLY HAVE TO DO WITH ONE FEDERAL
AGENCY THE FAA WHO LICENSE OUR
LAUNCH.
WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE IN A FEDERAL RANGE.
OR DO WE TRADE THAT OFF AND
SAVE ON THE JOYSTICKS BUT DAN.
HAVE THE INCREASED COSTS OF
DEALING WITH THE FEDERAL RANGE.
AND THAT RIGHT NOW THEY'RE ALL
CHOOSING TO GO ELSEWHERE.
.
THERE'S THERE'S SEVERAL OTHER
COMPANIES THAT.
SO IN ADDITION TO HAVE A POOR
LAUNCH CAPABILITY WHICH I TALKED
ABOUT.
I'LL OBVIOUSLY THESE COMPANIES
ALSO ONE EQUATORIAL LAUNCH SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE LOOKING AT
FLORIDA AND VIRGINIA.
AND.
IN THOSE STATES.
ESPECIALLY FLORIDA AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE SPACE FLORIDA
HAS BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
ATTRACTING BUSINESS THERE'D SO
THEY DO MATCHING INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS.
AND SO THE THE EXAMPLE THERE IS
YOU GOT TO START A COMPANY WHO
WANTS TO DO THEIR FIRST LAUNCH.
AND YOU CAN EITHER COME TO
CALIFORNIA AND.
INVEST A BUNCH OF MONEY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU NEED OR YOU
GO TO FLORIDAWHERE THE STATE OF
FLORIDA WILL INVEST IN YOUR
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY'RE GONNA
PROVE OUT THERE CONCEPTS IN
FLORIDA. AUGUST ONCE THEY PROVE
THEIR CONCEPTS THEY ALL THEIR
BUSINESS MODELS SAY. THE
CUSTOMERS ARE GONNA COME ONCE WE
START LAUNCHING SUCCESSFULLY.
RUN HAVE TONS OF CUSTOMERS AND
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO AFFORD YOU
EXTRA INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
PLACES.
PASSOVER SO RIGHT NOW I AM
UNITS.
IT IT'S OBVIOUS THAT THESE
COMPANIES AND INCLUDING ROCKET
LAB WOULD LOVE TO GET A LAUNCH
FROM CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY JUST FELT IT WAS
EASIER TO GO ELSEWHERE AND
THAT'S WHY THEY DECIDE TO BUILD
THEIR OWN OVERSEE SPACEPORT.
MMHM. DOT THE EIGHT ALSO BRINGS
UP CHALLENGES WHEN THESE
SO THESE COMPANIES ARE GOING
AFTER THE SMALL SET MARKET.
WHICH NOW THE GOVERNMENT'S
GETTING INTERESTED.
AND SO.
IT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY SMALL SAD SINCE AND
CLASSIFY PAYLOADS.
IT IT BECOMES MUCH MORE
CHALLENGING TO SHIP THE PAYLOAD
BECAUSE OF AYE TO OUR CONCERNS
OR.
OVER TO NW ZEALAND FOR A
LAUNCH OR EVEN UP TO ALASKA.
THEY WOULD THEY WOULD MUCH
RATHER KEEP IT.
LOCAL AND KEEP IT IN THE
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES
AND.
SO SO I I THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF INCENTIVES.
FOR.
FOR EVENTUALLY FOR THESE
COMPANIES TO BE HERE CALIFORNIA
BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT FOR
STARTING OUT.
OR.
YOU KNOW.
I I NOTICED ON YOUR MAP THAT TO.
THAT'S SPACEX'S BUILDING.
THE LAUNCH PAD IN TEXAS.
HIS IS. MAN I CAN ASK THEM AND
SEE IF AVARICE A RESPONSE BUT.
.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE THE.
IS IT IS THAT.
AN INDICATION THAT PERHAPS SOME.
.
OF THOSE.
SPACEX MANUFACTURING JOBS ARE
COULD BE FOLLOWING THE LAUNCH
PAD TO TEXAS.
WELL I I PLEDGE.
MAY LIE PROMESAS.
WHITE AND BUT I THINK YOU KNOW.
THE THE LOCATION OF THE LAUNCH
PAD OFTEN DEPENDS ON WHERE THE
LAUNCH IS GOING SO WE LAUNCH OUT
OF CAPE CANAVERAL AND. WERE
SENDING AYE.
ARE CARGO DRAGON CURRENTLY AND
EVENTUALLY CREW DRAG INTO
INTERNATIONAL SPACE STATION
SOMETIMES IT HAS MORE TO DO WITH
THE TRAJECTORY OF WHERE THE
LAUNCH IS GOING.
R. HOFFMAN FACILITY WE'RE NOW
UP TO A MILLION AND A HALF
SQUARE FEET.
AS OUR CAMPUS FOR OUR DESIGN
PRODUCTION MANUFACTURING SO
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT. I AM I THINK
THEY WOULD BE EAGER TO PICK UP
AND MOVE BUT YES THERE THEY ARE
LOOKING AT.
HOPE AN ADDITIONAL LAUNCH
FACILITY IN TEXAS. AND ALL OF
THAT HAS TO DO WITH IT BEING
FURTHER SOUTH EVEN ON THE CAPE
SO IT REALLY HAS TO DO WITH
WHERE THE LAUNCHERS ARE GOING.
AND. AND WE WE ARE RAMPING UP
OUR LAUNCH KIDS GOING OUT OF
VANDENBERG SO THERE'S STILL A
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT TO HEAR
TO CALIFORNIA HANDS AND WE
DON'T.
OR SEE THAT CHANGING BUT IN
TERMS OF THE THE THE LAUNCH IS
SET TO BE TAKING PLACE IN TEXAS.
AS OF NOW THE THE MANUFACTURING
TAKES PLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN THOSE. ROCKET SHIP YES
THOUGH ALL OF OUR ALL OF OUR
ROCKETS ARE MANUFACTURED HERE IN
OUR HAWTHORNE FACILITY. AND
THERE IS. WHEAT YOU HEARD FROM
OTHER PANELISTS THAT THEY DO
ENGINE TESTING AT DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS WE DO OUR TESTING AND
TEXAS.
.
BUT OUR MANUFACTURING IS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT TESTING ROCKET ENGINES AND
URBAN LOS ANGELES WOULD NOT BE
POSSIBLE. AND WHICH IS WHY ARE
TESTING FOR THE ENGINE FIRING
AND DOESN'T HAPPEN AT OUR
FACILITY BUT OUR MANUFACTURING
IS ALL HERE IN AND HAWTHORNE FOR
THE TIME BEING. OKAY THANK YOU.
.
AND SAY.
OF MR KAELIN IT'S A GALLON YES.
.
YOU.
POST A QUESTION WHY ARE THESE
WIRE SOME COMPANIES LAUNCHING
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA HE TALKED
ABOUT THE SPACE WORSE SPACEPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE REGULATORY HURDLES.
ALTHOUGH YOU INITIALLY START
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT. SOME OF THE CHALLENGES OF
COMPLYING WITH REGULATIONS FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT JUST
A STATE.
AROUND.
.
ARE YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT THIS
THE NEED FOR STREAMLINING
REGULATIONS THOSE ARE PRIMARILY.
IN THE AREA OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS.
YES SIR SO ENVIRONMENTAL.
AS WELL AS.
JUST IN GENERAL SAFETY
REGULATIONS WHICH IS BOTH
IT'S BOTH CAL OSHA AS WELL AS.
AT AS.
AT VANDERBURGH BEING ON THE
FEDERAL PROPERTY SO WE DO WHAT'S
WITH FEDERAL SAFETY AND DIED
VANDERBURGH SAFETY AS WELL.
.
THAT DAY.
WHILE A LOT OF TIMES THOSE THOSE
DIFFERENT REGULATIONS WHETHER
IT'S CALIFORNIA OR FEDERAL.
THEIR CONFLICTING.
SO IF A COMPANY IS.
.
DURING THEIR FIRST LAUNCHES IN
IN ALASKA WHERE THEY'RE A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
.
LENIENT ON SOME OF THOSE
REGULATIONS THAT WHEN THEY COME
TO TRANSPORT THEIR OPERATIONS TO
CALIFORNIA IF IT BRINGS ON
ADDITIONAL COSTS.
IT AS AT THE FAA MENTIONED YOUR
EVERY TIME THEY WANT. ANYONE OF
THESE COMPANIES WANTS TO LAUNCH
THAT. I GET SAME EXACT ROCKET
FROM A DIFFERENT SPACE PORT IT
IT GOES THROUGH A WHOLE NEW
LICENSING PROCESS HER SPACEPORT
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S SPECIFIC TO
THE LOCATION.
AND SO HOT SO NOT ONLY DO THEY
GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS WITH THE
FAA WHEN THEY COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEN THEY ALSO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WITH THE
FEDERAL RANGE AND AND FLYING ON
THE RANGE AND ALL THE RANGE
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT
THEY LEVY ON THEM. OKAY.
BUT THAT WOULD BE ON ONE OF THE.
PERHAPS AREAS THAT SHOULD WE
SUCCEED IN ESTABLISHING THE
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE COMMISSION
THAT THEY CAN TAKE THE LEAD IN
AND WORKING WITH THE FAA AND
ABSOLUTELY. OUT OKAY.
I WANT TO WELCOME A SENATOR
ALLEN.
THEY THEY CHAIR OF THE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON AEROSPACE AS
WELL AS.
MY PARTNER IN CRIME IN AND.
CHAMPIONING THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE COMMISSION WELCOME
SENATOR WHICH YOU WERE I'VE THAT
I THINK YOU I JUST WANNA POLICY
BECAUSE FOR TAKING SO LONG TO
GET HERE I WAS CHAIRING
EDUCATION I PRESENTED A BILL. IS
THE TIME OF THE YEAR.
BUT BUT I I CERTAINLY DID MIGHT
MY STAFF HAS BEEN MONITORING
THIS I'VE BEEN DOING SOME
REPORTS AND I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO BE HERE AND I'M.
VERY NICE IN THE TOPICS ON THE
TO BE SPENT SOME TIME GOING TO
THE MATERIALS.
AS. I THINK EVERYONE KNOWS AS
SENATOR ALAN.
AND I.
REPRESENT WHAT.
I DESCRIBED EARLIER AS THE
AEROSPACE CAPITAL THE WORLD.
THE.
THE EL SEGUNDO SOUTH BAY AREA.
.
AND.
VERY GOOD CAESAR. YEAH. SO.
.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY.
ABOUT TO WRAP UP HERE BUT.
.
MR KELSO.
OKAY.
MISTER MISTER PRIMER AND SAX
ACTUALLY.
I WANTED TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS
ALSO ON.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN A LAN
SITES AND WHERE MEN FASHION
TASTE BUDS ABSOLUTELY HAPPY
HAPPY TO THANK YOU FOR THE
INVITATION.
SO AS MYSTERIES IS INDICATED
EARLIER ARE ALL THE VIRGIN
COMPANIES ALWAYS HAVE AND I
ANTICIPATE ALWAYS WILL
MANUFACTURE ALL OF OUR VEHICLES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
HUMAN SPACE FLIGHT SYSTEM RIGHT
THERE IN THE HOBBY AND ARE A
BILL ON SYSTEM I. DOWN DOWN IN
LONG BEACH.
AS MYSTERIES ALSO INDIATED WE
WILL LAUNCH FROM A HOBBY BUT
ALSO FROM OTHER PLACES SO FOR
THE HUMAN SPACE FLIGHT PROGRAM
ALL THE TEST LAUNCH IS NOT JUST
FOR THE FIRST VEHICLES THAT BUT
FOR ALL THE SUBSEQUENT ONES THAT
WE BUILD THOSE WILL ALWAYS OCCUR
FOR MOJAVE.
MY HAT'S OFF TO TO MYSTERIES
FOR OUT FOR AS SHE AS SHE
INDICATED HAVING A FACILITY THAT
REALLY DOES MANAGE AIRCRAFT LIKE
OPERATIONS AIRLINE LIKE
OPERATIONS WHERE WE CAN DO
THINGS THAT. ON RELATIVELY SHORT
NOTICE AND WITHOUT WITH A LIGHT
FOOTPRINT IN A AND A LOW COST
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEED.
SO THE THE TEST FLIGHTS WILL
HAPPEN FROM.
WILL HAPPEN FROM A HOBBY THAT
COMMERCIAL FLIGHTS WILL HAPPEN
FROM THAT FROM THE STATE OF NEW
MEXICO AND POTENTIALLY FROM
OTHER LOCATIONS AND
EACH YEAR. AND THAT IS A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF A TOURISM ACTIVITY
THAT IS AN AEROSPACE ACTIVITY ON
THE OFFICE IT'S AT THE
INTERSECTION BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THOSE.
FOR THE VIRGIN ORBIT SIDE OF THE
HOUSE AND WITH OUR ORBITAL
SATELLITE LAUNCH PROGRAM AGAIN
WE HAVE A WE JUST ACQUIRED A NEW
FACILITY IN ADDITIONAL FACILITY
AT DOUGLAS PART IN LONG BEACH SO
WE'RE EXPANDING OUR PRESENCE
THERE AND.
AND HAVE NO PLANS TO OR
INTERESTS FRANKLY IN IN IN IN
EVER LEAVING THEIR IT'S A
WONDERFUL HOME FOR MONTHS.
OUT WE WILL LAUNCH FROM MANY
DIFFERENT PLACES IT'S ONE OF OUR
MAIN. COMPETITOR TO MANAGES THE
THINGS THAT WE OFFER TO OUR
CUSTOMERS THE ABILITY TO FLY
THEIR SATELLITES FROM WHERE THEY
WANT TO FLY TO WHERE THEY WANT
TO FLY FROM.
SO ALL OF OUR INITIAL TEST
FLIGHTS WILL HAPPEN ALSO FROM A
HOBBY AT IT'S A FANTASTIC
FACILITY FOR US TO LAUNCH INTO
WHAT ARE CALLED POLAR
INCLINATION ORBITS OVER BITS
THAT GO OVER THE NORTH POLE AND
THE SOUTH POLE. NOT SO WE'LL BE
DOING OUR FIRST POLAR LAUNCH
FROM A HOBBY IN A MATTER OF
MONTHS.
AND THEN NOT ONLY OUR TEST
FLIGHTS WILL HAPPEN THERE BUT
MANY PERHAPS ALL OF OUR PORT
POLAR FLIGHTS WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN FROM THERE. AND POLAR
LAUNCHES OUR A FAIRLY LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF OF OF THAT TERM
COMMERCIAL MET DEMAND THAT WE'VE
SEEN THUS FAR.
FOUR SATELLITES I WANT TO GO TO
OTHER ORBITAL DESTINATIONS THAT
MAYBE ONE OF YOUR BRING AROUND
THE EQUATOR RATHER THAN AROUND
THE POLES. OUT BOTH THE LAWS OF
NATURE AND THE LAWS OF HUMANS
INDICATE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
PROBABLY NOT THE RIGHT PLACE FOR
THAT DO YOU REALLY WANT TO
LAUNCH FROM SOMEWHERE THAT'S A
MUCH LOWER LATITUDE. AND SO
THAT'S WHY PLACES FOR OTHER
SPACE COMPANIES AND FOR USAS
WELL PLACES LIKE FLORIDA OR THE
MARSHALL ISLANDS OR A BARGE
THAT'S IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PACIFIC.
HAVE STARTED TO BE MORE
ATTRACTIVE FOR THOSE IT'S A
CERTAINLY WE WILL BE LAUNCHING
FROM FROM LOTS OF DIFFERENT
PLACES BUT I ANTICIPATE THAT
CALIFORNIA WILL ALWAYS BE AN
IMPORTANT.
PLACE THAT WERE ABLE TO OFFER
TUCKED OUR CLIENTELE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SERTANEJA VIA.
QUESTIONS SUMMER YES.
WELL IT DIDN'T SLOW PREFER SPACE
SECTION AND I AND I THINK THAT
WE DIDN'T MAKE A GOOD POINT OF
THAT THE REASON WHY WE'RE
BUILDING MCALLEN'S TO BE FURTHER
SOUTH. THEN AND THEN THE CAPE
AND THAT IS REALLY FOR. OUR
LUNCHES GOING AROUND THE ORBITAL
GREATER.
ART VANDENBERG IS THIS IS
USUALLY PER POLAR LAUNCHES.
PRODUCES. AS.
VIRGIN SAID IT'S.
ALL ABOUT PHYSICS SO.
WE. WERE NOT THAT WE'RE NOT
MOVING AND BUILDING A NEW
FACILITY FOR REASONS OTHER THAN.
THE THE BUSINESS OF WE YOU KNOW
OF THAT LAUNCH.
DEMANDS.
THANK YOU.
.
YOU HAVE THE POWER.
ALRIGHT.
SO MISTER KELSEY TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE.
ACTIVITIES TAKING PLACE AROUND
THE FAA CENTER FOR EXCELLENCE
FOR COMMERCIAL SPACE.
TRANSPORTATION.
.
YOU SET FORTH.
SOME.
.
NEITHER WORK IN TERMS OF THE
AEROSPACE COMMISSION WORKING
WITH THE AIRFORCE AND NASA THE.
SUPPORT FOR MOJAVE AND OTHER
POTENTIAL SPACE PORTS.
.
YEAH SO I THINK A.
YEAH SHE JUST WERE LOOKING FOR
NOT IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT WE WERE
ASKING ABOUT YOU KNOW SOME TO
WHAT SPACE FLORIDA DOESN'T AND
FLORA FOR NASA.
WOULD THERE BE SOME SIX AND
CASINO CAME FROM THE COMMITTEE
TO.
TO SOME SIMILAR GAL OR.
SO I I THINK I MEAN I I KNOW
THAT WHEN AND WHENEVER I'M A.
MAKING MY PICKS FOR THE BILL AND
AS I'LL BE MAKING THE PITCH TO
OUR SENATORS AND AND.
HAVE.
PASSED THE BATON DO CENTER ALLEN
HOPEFULLY WHEN HE GETS TO THE
FLOOR.
.
AND THEN WELL WILL LOBBY THE
GOVERNOR BUT.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THIS
COMMISSION IS TO CHAMPION.
AEROSPACE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND TO. RECOGNIZE THAT
OTHER STATES ARE ACTIVELY TRYING
TO.
LURE.
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY ARE MEANT
AEROSPACE JOBS FROM CALIFORNIA.
.
AND.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT.
.
YOU KNOW SUPPORTING MOJAVE
ANOTHER POTENTIAL SPACE SPORTS.
WOULD SUPPORT. KEEPING THE
MANUFACTURING JOBS IN CALIFORNIA
I I CERTAINLY SEE THAT AS AS
PART OF.
THAT THE MISSION OF OF THIS
PROPOSED COMMISSION.
ON THE HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS.
I I WILL DEFINITELY SAY THAT.
A LOT OF US IN THE INDUSTRY ARE
ARE.
YOU KNOW VERY WELL VERSED ON
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL STATE LEVEL AND IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. OF WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO SHARE ANY OF
THAT INFORMATION A WITH THE
COMMISSION.
IT WHENEVER WHENEVER NECESSARY
SO ALWAYS HAVE HER HAPPY TO
PURCHASE IN ANSWERING QUESTIONS
OKAY.
AND DO WE GET INTO THE ROLE OF
NASA DRIVE BECOME KIND OF AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
DISCUSSION.
OR LIKE WERE AND WHERE YOU SEE
THE FUTURE OF NASA GOING GIVEN
THAT.
WHAT'S GONNA TELL GOVERNMENT.
OF WE WE REALLY DIDN'T I THINK.
.
THERE'S I MEAN THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN.
REALLY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE COMMERCIAL COMPANIES
WHETHER IT'S NASSER DOD.
AND A LOT OF THESE COMMERCIAL
COMPANIES ARE STARTING TO SEE A
LOT MORE PARTICIPATION.
AS NOT JUST
IT'S NOT JUST THE OLD SPACE
COMPANIES LIKE BOEING LOCKHEED
NORTHRUP THE TRADITIONAL
CONTRACT OF WINTERS OF SOME OF
THESE. CONTRACTS FOR CITIES
INITIATIVES IT'S IT'S NOW SPACEX
WHO WERE CHEN VIRGIN GALACTIC.
THESE ARE COMPANIES THAT ARE
NOW REALLY.
A PLAYER IN AND WITH. THE DOD
IN THE NASA CONTRACTOR.
BUT SO ARE ARE FOCUSED.
YEAH I HAS BEEN ON THE
COMMERCIAL.
A SIDE OF US.
THAT THE SPACE INDUSTRY.
WE WE HEARD AND NOW I FORMA
SPACEX AND VIRGIN GALACTIC AND
AND THE AFFILIATED TO VERSION
ORBIT.
THE FAMILY OF COMPANIES I
BELIEVE WAS YOUR YOUR TERM.
BUT ALSO.
.
THE.
GROWING SPACE.
ENTREPRENEURIAL ISM.
AND AND THE ROLE OF VENTURE
CAPITAL WE HAVE THE SO THIS IS
REALLY IS A MATTER OF FACT
RECREATION PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO
SPACE TO SEE IT ALL WE TALKED
ABOUT THAT AND ABOUT TO IN THE
NEXT TEN YEARS HOPEFULLY.
SIR BRANSON WILL BE.
THAT THE FIRST.
SPACE TRAVELER IN THE NEXT TEN
YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT I AND I THINK I
HEARD THERE RIGHT. HIM.
AND THAT.
HOPEFULLY IN OUR LIFETIMES WILL
HAVE A LEGISLATIVE DELEGATION AT
SPACE ACTION HAVE.
YEAH ALRIGHT.
OKAY ALTHOUGH THROUGH HISTORY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
BUT THIS IS SURROUND THE OTHER
THING I'D SAY ABOUT NASA.
.
SO WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT.
THIS REVOLUTION WITH SMALL
SATELLITES AND COMMERCIAL SMALL
SATELLITES
AND.
THE VENTURE CAPITALISTS AND
THAT NOW THERE'S ACCESS
TO SPACE EXPLOITATION FROM
UNIVERSITIES AND HIGH SCHOOLS
AND.
BECAUSE YOU CAN BUILD THE
SATELLITES WITH COMMERCIAL OFF
THE SHELF PRODUCTS.
.
FROM THE GOVERNMENT SIDE.
BOTH NASA AND DEPARTMENT
DEFENSE.
ARE ALSO MAKING HUGE
INVESTMENTS RIGHT NOW IN THE
SMALL SATELLITE INDUSTRY.
IN. THEY JUST LIKE THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET THEY NEED
ROCKETS THAT CAN LAUNCH THESE
SMALL SETS AND.
AND SO SOME OF THOSE ROCKETS
REPRESENTED HERE.
AT THE CALIFORNIA SPACEPORT I'M
REPRESENTING THE OTHER COMPANIES
THAT ARE STILL TRY TO DEVELOP
THESE ROCKETS THAT WERE TRYING
TO ATTRACT THEM TO LAUNCH FROM
CALIFORNIA.
AND DIED THERE WHILE THEY'RE
WITH A PITCH TO THE VENTURE
CAPITALIST IT'S MOSTLY THIS
COMMERCIAL MARKET BUT THEY THEY
ALL ARE BEING TOLD. ONCE YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL ONCE YOU PUT A FEW
THINGS ON ORBIT. OF THE
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS ARE GOING
TO FALL RIGHT UP AND.
SOURCE SONG I I SEE I SEE NASA
PLAYING A HUGE ROLE IN.
SMALL SAT LAUNCHES IN FUTURE TO.
THAT ARE YOU DO MUCH COVERAGE
WITH THE EUROPEAN SPACE.
AUTHORITIES.
OUR IS SO NOT US SPECIFICALLY
BUT I WOULD REFER TO THE FAA ON
OUR YEAH WE WE ARE DEATHLY
COORDINATING WITH THAT THE
PRAIRIES INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES
ABOUT THEIR INTERESTS AND
LAUNCHING FROM THEIR LOCATIONS
AND THEY BRING IN THEIR SERVICE
OVER HERE TO TO THE UNITED
STATES AS WELL SO. THERE'S
ONGOING CONVERSATION.
WE'RE HAVING VISITORS COME.
OVER TIME A HOBBY SPACEX VARIOUS
COMPANIES. ARE VISITING AND SEE
HOW THEY OPERATE TO GET AN IDEA
OF WHAT'S EXPECTED AND WHAT THE
CURRENT REGIME IS.
MARK I I AS I SAY I I DO
APOLOGIZE FOR MISSING WASN'T
HEARING AT THIS IS.
PROBLEM WITH OUR LITTLE CITY
SHARING YOUR COMMITTEE YEAH I
THINK EVERYTHING ANDERSON.
RIGHT.
BUT I I DO LOOK FOR DIFFERENT
MATERIALS THINKING YEAH I HAVE
ONE CLOSING COMMENT JUSTICE TO
SAY THAT WE RECOGNIZE.
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES THAT THAT
SOME OF THE COMPANIES ARE
DEALING WITH NOW.
SO IN OUR STREAMLINING EFFORT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES IN PARTICULAR.
A SPACE PORT DOES COLOR CAVE
AIRPORT.
LAUNCHING AT VARIOUS SITES.
ON THE FEDERAL RANGE FIRST IS
THE THE NOT ARRANGE REGIME WOULD
FIND IT MERGE THOSE TOGETHER
MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT. AND
WORKING MORE STREAM I PUT THE
DIFFERENT COMPANIES. OKAY
CHILEAN WORK IRATE AND.
.
NO I I THINK I CAN I CAN SAY AS
A.
THE ACTING CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE THAT
YOU KNOWN WHERE ON.
WERE.
I AM OPEN TO HEARING SPECIFIC
IDEAS ON HOW WE CAN STREAMLINE.
SOME OF THE. ENVIRONMENTAL
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE WERE VERY
PROUD OVER VERY PROTECTIVE OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
.
YOU KNOW LEADERSHIP ROLE AND.
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY BETA.
IF THERE STREAMLINING MEASURES
THAT MAKE SENSE.
I'M ALL EARS.
NARRATOR.
IF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
EVERYONE FOR COMING OUT THING
YOU KNOW THAT WE GOT CA MTA ALSO
IN THE HOUSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SHAW FOR.
FOR SITTING THROUGH THE WHOLE
PRESENTATION AND.
.
I THINK WHERE GENTRA OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.